I see it on my side
have you seen a good coach well yet he's
the bushes with the for me Oh bad bits
in me I see a lot of people in the bad
bit right there already know you know we
love everywhere no I was waiting for my
coals give me these give me man so you
must've stepped away anyway welcome to
the ILO's podcast in the Lords of gaming
dotnet episode number 141 and it's
another glorious Sunday we're back at
the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
very excited about our special guests
and we've got the PS file logo and
console reveal status no Xbox series X
exclusives switch Pro rumors and pokemon
dlc to discuss so we go get right into
it I want to introduce the Lord who the
ILP initially crossed paths with at e3
2019 now is just learned one of our
bright young stars within the Xbox
community but he also exudes tremendous
gaming passion in an analytical yet
objective podcast package introducing
the create and host of the Xbox
expansion pass and member of ILP mixes
for UT the full-time teacher by day and
owner of the best achievement podcast
sound by night laughs from North
Carolina right making his debut into the
realm of the Lords my man Lord look Lord
aka the incepted ghost how you doing sir
dude I'm so excited to be here with you
guys oh okay all week it's an honor it's
a privilege oh my goodness the energy
that you guys bring every week the
positivity you bring every week it's
it's Bar None the best and I'm so stoked
to be with you guys
for a bunch of fresh air
log overdue we were talking for a while
we knew it had to happen you know say
King had the privilege of meeting you so
now we got to do this thing right rolled
out the red carpet for the ghosts in the
realm of us yes you already build a
glass of fun man no doubt and I want to
introduce four horsemen but I wanna make
sure one is here
is he here before I go to a long spiel
of an intro for him I'm pretty sure
you're suffering to me but I don't know
and that was my co-host with the co-host
brother the difficult game Conqueror
Lord of reviews and the hop of the young
wolf mommy
Lord addict I desert doing pretty good
I'm pretty sure stuffs about to go left
right knockdown if I go left no I don't
think there's Mike topics today it's
fitting right now that green boy in the
back you see see that green land tours
happen you know what it is what I think
it's maybe switch time he saw switch
topics he got a little timid anybody
well if you could you could correct him
and and say that you pick that topic to
the couch I can't believe I get this
over the budzma Network but speaking of
which I can we have before we get it so
Eddie what have you sir Pokemon
101 and he beat me in the third round
yeah we both had to say Paul kobold used
to say moving and they they pretty much
did a 50-50 chance and who went first
and he went and they gave it to him
you all right Xbox it was crazy man
the same Pokemon we did you say the
Ellen I'd stop talking about with you
tell me about what you did did you L it
out clearly I just said he was down to
the wire the game just gave it to one of
us okay and gave it to him so you and
the bushes know in Pokemon when you use
the same move with the same speed it
just flips a coin on who goes first
and you lost that toy besides poke my
wife good laser that's all I've been
playing that Frost Punk actually on game
past I've been playing that
oh and of course are not frauding not
pocket watching most technical game he
says mad cuz last week you know we
little as lose all over over the pages
the solo gave a who'll is for the
single-player selfish experience and
also the sastra Damas mister off my
profile Illuminati and lore patron of
the iron bank mommy
Lord sovereign I will exert do a good
good morning general good to me because
I actually woke up in the morning unlike
the rest of the I didn't even give you
that one today why was that cuz that's
not a thing that happens to be dragging
his knees in it my boss I can't be
working on more time
for about three months I told her I
couldn't do till the magma luigi's
mansion on the switz when I'm not at
home and I played a little bit
it isn't very good excellent beautiful
game um and then control trying to get
to control you I was expected you have
to tell me you have to tell me how much
of that game you actually played and you
know we ended it but how oh good no no
you know what I mean how you made how
much I played from beginning to end how
much did you speed or run through the
game is what I'm nervous
did you get the collectables what he
does you know you're not a collectible
guy fine glass to every rock to see the
whole game the Internet you didn't beat
the game unless you save states you
didn't do this did remedy games are
known for having a lot of in-game stuff
pertain to the story you know me and
remedy games are we're parting ways
[Laughter]
you don't like collecting those back
taxes that is not an excuse not about
that life
I respect him he about getting that
review of maybe beat it first and then
you can't talk to you because you a beat
what's funny
other games you know they get Chris
ridiculed for for putting in text to
make the story more enlightened but
apparently control it's okay a menu
percent of the story
the pages of grimoire to find out how
you can be it's only allowed if you're
in grimoire cards he hasn't been playing
control he's been reading control and of
course we have the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the XS game you know act like
you didn't know that was code of combat
sports king of the statues who the bears
nothing lasted that premium experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert move
it
who beloved Lord K how you doing sir
oh boy I'm doing incredible right now we
got a lot of topics oh did you get a
chance to see the happy McGee a fight
last night where else Michael Sullivan
Michael Sullivan has a handlebar
mustache
you know Ron Kaiser Rakesh Megan's
boxing those dudes went at it last night
I saw ask his soul jump out his body
when having my gear got caught with a
right hand
it was him and Bernard Hopkins a meal
ticket was enough but it was a great
fight shoutout to charissa shields the
quote the the greatest box of all times
and she only has ten fights and she's
doing this at an unprecedented level the
only thing that I'm sad at is that she
doesn't have a contemporary that can
match her skill you know um usually she
kind of she caught like a boy
the prom type when it wasn't really
enough for a cog it's even worse than
that there's no one there you know he
wrote he had Bernard that is absolutely
zero females that can match her skills
speed and is at the point now I'm saying
to myself well maybe she needs to fight
men oh is this at that point that her
skill level is too far
she says she surpasses them she had I
think it was six heavyweight champion
I'm not happy with our champions current
and former champions walk out men
holding her belts walking to the Rings
and um the level of respect that the men
give her this it's it's something that
if you've never seen a fight and you're
your female or your mail is just
actually like good boxing she would be
super check King gotta know how you like
in the bf2 campaign yes um let's get to
what I'm playing right all right so this
week somebody hit me on my timeline I
don't know his name because I'm about to
slander you owe me yo you want a free
game mm-hmm oh I'm in my Star Wars mold
right now and I was like Jedi fallen on
her I'm saying I was ready so he hits me
in the DME like email gave me no yes has
gone so he sends me the the the game
code no no glasses on putting the game
cold in will make it scream big so I
could see the words right and it said
region a lot talk to some that so a lot
more about you know how you
you give somebody some cake and go not
for you for you and it was like because
of it it kind of fooled me at first
because it was in Spanish when he said I
don't care about that but the code and
no no no game so discover to come and
save the day so I had to go redeem my
Negro bucks
Wow send me the bread so I'm waiting for
that car to come nowwhat and I got a
play that too is in game pass but I've
been playing battlefront - Oh as a
battle great our own stall was yo talk
to me talk let me talk to me I'm ready
for this I engine for that game made me
feel like I'm in a Star Wars movie
story you start to feel a side of the
arm of the order like you know like how
they fighting and you get a different
perspective and then you start to see
that tri-cities day was committing on
their own people and it made you
understand why dudes were jump to the
rebel side and then Luke Skywalker's
dead old Luke and I'm playing looking
and he's like you know my piece beyond
with you in his like you like he's
playing with Jesus did you spare me give
me a choice give me a choice and I'm
like go home I said he told to do it at
the end like he left them he's gonna be
the force be with you so dude use the
same one later in the game like cuz I'm
playing the campaign for Juno yeah and
he used the same line later to some
other dude may the force be with you and
I was like wow this is just a religious
cult type the game what he said is
unreal for unreal
so acting like we don't know what
that'll front to now that's the only
thing the front fight works well with
its right that's frostbite know about
this centric age within $10 super chair
please brother say something afterwards
wanna shout you out out no all right I
was playing that in destiny but I'm so
locked in on it because it gives you a
chance to use like people powers like I
was using Princess Leia because they
have heroes in the game she has to play
one of the big battles where you like
with 44 people and it just gives you the
whole epic fill and also I was playing
in a TIE fighter and an x-wing it is EA
I'm so happy that I came back to a game
that was on EA access shout out to he
access that debuted on Xbox the only
people that supported you
oh please you know they needed some type
of service because they don't have a
service about the EA access that you
know dupe me for that extra 35 so I'm
like thank for the year again check
question for the panel have y'all seen
the video by mbg about how the PS 5 will
be able to outperform the Xbox series X
with its secret sauce three instruction
SIMD on SIMD Saahil Ares or did she for
you instead of the regular 2d I thought
we will get to said topics we have a lot
to discuss you see the green right you
see you see the Pharaoh right so yeah
I'm coming from connect little lady
gamer hold on to that we will definitely
address that when we get to P has five
topics and stuff to discuss a big a big
cloud gaming what's going on man slow mo
what's going on but that's been it Kings
been the the battle for our front and
all that good stuff
I'm a little bit under the weather so
good man of course we have the gaming
engine himself the shinobi lore kognito
sprite never illness in the room and I
LP not telling you what you want to hear
but what you need to hear got the
reading going on
salute to my 49ers oh right now the gang
where y'all at well I see I see falls in
there you know Z so this is ready go
lords of gaming style 9 is Edition but
also Real Talk man if we lose all our
time line with this 49 already go baby
ready go Diwali I'm feeling good by that
listen man we are ahead of schedule
you know this I'm feeling real good
right now you don't put on this once in
one thing your joint yeah without those
right even spill right now PC senior
side how they hype them up he's done an
MC game y'all imma so I thank you might
win this year hey I don't want to get
gas we still got some hurdles but army
it feels like a special team I will say
that physic special team and your boy
it's feeling good yeah rock it out do
some stuff a Tablas fun but um yeah
shout to my boy guy basu in of course
attic last night forcing me to finish
kids
wait wait wait we're up to the final
chapter they got big black I just did
like that desert
be real the desert level with open world
I know the Xbox community gonna come at
me but it's just like the whole like it
just seems like a sheet of orange paste
and I just didn't like I like what do
you want to skip in the snow and it
looked good now now do respect to the
paced when you walk in it and you see
the dust and how it kicks up under there
when they're in inner fire
you know I'm saying but that board it
just dragged it I'm like oh my god and
then when we got to the fire and you
fight that thing I call it the Body
Snatcher
and that thing this snatching them that
layer I like that that joint was intense
whatever what is just typical gears like
you're on a scaffolding you fall 300,000
feet and everybody's armor they wearing
yes you have to double take I don't know
what level of motion capture they're
using but that is so amazing that the
banter with JD and all he's got a shout
out to Oh Marcus he got one of the
classic lines in that drink because he
said what's the most savage seas like
well what's your name
shut up and you know the thing is they
did a lot of good stuff in that gears
those wide linear levels it's too empty
- that's from problem the desert level
is to empty their nothing I think I
quite made the desert like when you're
talking about you know the the second
act and it's all ice it makes sense that
it was painted right yeah well you're
talking like this open area and you hit
and I like there let go help these
people and then they don't do anything
but they don't interact it's like so I
just saved you what you know I had the
thing when we played it yesterday I was
like every time they're like let's go
help these people with the waters like
know or not but do shout-out to the
writing because they nailed the ride in
between Kate and
yes by the end of it dude I there are
things that happen and begin to choose
certain things those chooses were brutal
cuz like do you respect JD from back in
years or and give him a better story now
but del they made you love del by live
all of it stocking with del all honey
but say anything yeah - is that addict
showed me one of the chapters before
when you had to Kate was going through
something like you if you're a play he
made me play his cake for one minute
he's like no play with her he said
you've seen what you're experiencing
right now we don't see that and I'm like
so it gave me a level of appreciation
for the writing and the character
ability individuality and what I like is
a lot of the jokes don't feel forced it
feels like natural banter so salute to
them or now you know I'm saying it but
like I said almost there
after being me no attica after you know
what and I got everybody throw something
in the bushes because you know I'm a
being the bushes forever there you know
what's the funny thing we can't play
that I joined that game like it was fun
it was fun like we got to the part we
were practicing how to escape back to
back what when you was passing the thing
in the cell to follow that kid got
caught cuz he passes back I was like kid
it's two buttons he's like I don't know
what happened to Kyle you know pushing
me through we'll get that done so by
next ILP your boys backlog will be much
lighter one of the biggest games
finished but um yeah real quick before
we jump into the rest of the show I want
to hit up
oh man shout the face 23 ok BK and why
flat-out a super chat Jason Schreyer
says PlayStation 5 will lost with
exclusive games while Xbox next
generation is to release on as many
platforms as possible I must say that
with negative energy because I'm
assuming you bring the tech man
but before we jump on can tell you what
I've been playing real quick yes please
cuz I want I want to tell you I liked
like King I've been playing battlefront
2 well I went back to that game because
I you know launched what it was it had a
lot of issues I went back and checked it
out since Roger Skywalker cuz I was
feeling fallen order and I was playing
with the Lord bad bit having so much fun
so much fun jumping in there with those
heroes they really did real talk
they cleaned up that game and made that
progression feel good and I want to give
due credit cuz we we we dunk on EA a lot
deservedly I might add but for frostbite
to work and their progression to be
fixed fraps to you and I even got into
Darksiders because of the backlogs you
do what you do yeah game pass gives what
it gives and I got into Darksiders I'm
so stoked for a for Darksiders Genesis I
ended up getting the the statue for
Darksiders 3 excited up like in a game
great double a game love that double a
game I couldn't my backlog was already
clear of control because I had one KD I
didn't need those collectibles just
throw that out there I'd finish that I
don't know but no I wanted to give due
credit to battlefront too because it's
way better than when it was you know and
I appreciate that we've seen it with
destiny and so many others when you go
back and fix a game that that deserves
wow you know what I'm gonna go check
anthem this week because somebody
purchased and it forced me to play the
game so like you've done your time man I
feel like you could play with them go
there's a lot to enjoy in anthat gets
dunked on deservedly but there if you're
not trying to get a Bioware game and you
just want to fly around and feel like I
am in a giant like that's Philly Eagle
game you lost something to it it's just
I got a hundred plus hours into a UK UK
I was waiting for the Frog to show up
because I just
I'm curious like you know our guest is
talking pretty positive by anthem you
sure we don't like things somewhat of a
gun do you head in the background hey
hey man you know actually I'm not I'm
giving credit where it's due and that
game flubbed plenty I just like flying
around being Iron Man I never got in a
Tony Stark's - I guess that's all it is
[Applause]
crazy but anyway real quick just before
we get into it man special announcement
obviously I want to thank the everyone
once again man who support Lords a game
in.net man pretty much great feedback if
you read any article retweeted any
articles we did any of the like man we
really appreciate it we had one of our
biggest months in December
you know the Mission Continues as you
can see we got the trip one so make sure
you get that Lords of gaming trip on a
tee spring if you can but please be on
the lookout for the Lords at PAX East
2020 your boys are medium and such
salute to the team we are officially
media capaci span 2020 we're gonna try
to bring you the best coverage you're
getting salute to the team everybody you
see dizzy in here undead the whole squad
you don't put the bending emoji been
immediate Mogi Mirim
bend the knee you know cuz a lot of
people thought that uh something that we
couldn't do or you know they put doubt
in the air and um I just wanna say
something just because I didn't tweet
that I'm media want to know you know how
does that feel you know who you suck you
know more interested in King yeah I'm
more interested in though you go into
2pac stress to that that that lantern
back
you know the Green Team is definitely
gonna be on this move I see you I heard
you might be Lincoln I see you smoke I
see you about this is right what y'all
don't understand is the level of hard
work that cog puts around in the
background and how hard he and how
diligent you know we push forward it was
something that I always knew was gonna
happen and shout out to dizzy you know
with the hard work oh yeah I was talking
you know about dizzy this week I know
years was ringing brother
I truly appreciate everything that you
do all the hard work from the right is
what it seemed everybody forward
everybody the truth on day three XVI
Ormoc mood condors condor down your maid
Jean I mean the list goes or Hector
Ramirez man up boy you know saying hi
I've been like listen this is a team
effort and at the end of the day you
guys chose to say look we want to
support something from the ground up
right for us give your opinions even if
I don't agree I still post it but at the
end of the day like look man is it's all
about creative expression and um just
something by the game is right yeah you
guys I said you know you're tired of
listening to other people for opinions
you want to go to the gamers that
actually play these games and get busy
and to see y'all doing it it's
tremendous and because of y'all we are
where we are so keep it up we got more
things playing your packs is gonna be
lit this 2020 we got a lot of stuff
cooking for y'all I just know I'm in on
Coggs neck for those people have joined
the realm what he explained to me is at
this packs all the B footage that we
have is going to be released as for you
guys that join the realm so all the
outtakes and you know King flooded me
stuff that you not only go see hmm you
gonna see it there yeah but you pre she
a guy go see a lot of stuff to go get it
so but we got to get this show
going I've been rambling but um yeah now
we got to announcement and all that I
want to introduce that Lord you know
that's the special Lord that we have
here in the realm you don't say so if we
were to start with the Lord incepted
ghost his video game system history his
journey podcasting and of course our
mixture and what led him to creating the
amazing Xbox expansion past so logos
let's start from the very beginning what
are some of the first video game systems
you had and what got you into gaming
oh man first video game systems I had
NES but it I got an NES when everybody
else was getting n64 in PlayStation
family what family wasn't we didn't have
the dollars to throw two video games at
the time because my parents were getting
it done taking care of us right and in
the moment I realized with the video
game that I could press a button and
make something happen on screen I was
hooked I was hooked I mean that was me
finding odd jobs around the house around
the neighborhood so I can buy so I could
upscale it from nes SNES and Genesis and
I just worked my way until finally I was
able to get a ps2 at launch mmm that was
like I mean I worked I worked my butt
off trying to make that happen and so
much so that uh I was embarrassed again
let's go let's go that was in college I
worked my way through school kind of
thing but what I couldn't afford an Xbox
360 I saw I said that's for me the day I
came home with that 360 and that gears I
never saw that plasma place again again
and I loved it your nobody can tell
fit about ghost Ville he lives about it
I just I just love games and Real Talk
my favorite game system of choice at any
given time is the one that makes me feel
the most that I get the most happiness
out of and that doesn't mean anybody
else can't enjoy whatever it is they
enjoy and that's my big thing like right
now Xbox is my main console of choice
don't mean I don't love got a war don't
owe spider-man don't love playing
infamous make sure you face what it's
just oh dude I'm a good credible one
rebel already tell you breath the wild
something special it took me a while you
over that those weapons breaking but
Girl Talk like I love video games the
world that what it does for people it
gets people out of out of depressions
and excitement and so is it gets us
through everything I can win the World
Cup something I never be able to do
thanks for video game I can wear space
armor I was Batman so many times
thanks to those Arkham games and so
that's the thing man I love games for
that reason and beautiful and that's
that's it what else can I tell you about
it well basically you started their
generation you started off they're gay
she gave up the plasma the platelets
they gave it up I respect it so that was
the first sort of clarify that was the
first system yeah the very first was
that one that i'm i'm i think i bought
ps2 with my own money now I had and I
had all the systems just not when they
were in in the main stage I'm saying you
got my hood effect right exactly but by
the time I 360 was there I was I was
there early on in it launched we on day
woman I think you to get on on weeks it
was little cheaper but did you get ps3
at all or was you kind of like yeah you
kind of stuck in that ecosystem he was
stuck $100 he said no yeah I think yeah
we pulled money together so I could play
metal gear for he was not donating the
kidney nah no I didn't I didn't have the
organs to give up on that one but I did
end of life and I think everybody should
do that if you missed out on exclusives
from any system once it gets
cost-effective and we might even be
seeing this with the sad Edition right
now once you get a chance to enter into
that ecosystem go back and play what you
missed
I can check out good games you missed
and I did that with ps3 towards the
topic for that later
oh and last question about the consoles
were there any handheld in between that
period you mess with any hails or at all
you were strictly mostly a console guy
mostly console but just by the nature
going to classes I mean I did have a
Vita love the shadow from the Vita great
system let us do the switch thankfully
which is nice yes and I had a DS Lite
remember that DS brick you had that for
like a second I was like oh the lights
here yeah I switch to the light and some
great gradius game the bad bit
he said ps3 was a mortgage payment
before you purchased it that you had to
get the second job they did primarily
chapter misko do G isn't he I would say
coated Oh Betty you see yeah go straight
invite him back again yeah we go do what
they say thank you thank you already
know so tremendous history man love love
dedication on that so let's get into the
the podcast in aspect and she one thing
obviously you know I came across you I
mean actually King came across you in
the flesh obviously acting doing stuff
like that but you're known in the
podcast world and I know you started off
initially I think with the xbox drive
and then eventually which led you to the
amazing Xbox expansion podcast which for
the record y'all let me tell you right
now professionally done you know one of
my opinion like I said I mean we was
speaking offline but you know I feel so
low podcasting is an art and as an audio
podcast
the kid is informative he knows his
stuff and it's a great solo cast so just
get the inspiration about you getting
into the podcast game oh man so long ago
in another life I was a sports
journalist for major league soccer and I
ran a podcast in the soccer world
talking to pro athletes Pro general
managers coaches
really really loved that aspect and
engaging with people that way that that
career did not pan out and I returned
back to teaching which I do now which is
great but what I find is that my
favorite hobby comes from video games
and sharing just the conversations you
get on Twitter in social media discord
whatnot and podcasting is a great way to
do it I had the brilliant amazing
opportunity to join Shaun Capri on the
Xbox Drive all solution for those early
build him the 10 DeLauro bet that's like
the fam write all of them that's right
and those are my people and Shaun his
energy and passion is infectious
yes it's exciting and so so on the best
and worst of days it was always clear he
loved podcasting he needed a host for
the Xbox Drive at one point he was
gracious enough to let me into that
family and for a year we had some
incredible conversations we went to e3
we went to fan fest best three days of
my life
mmm so much good times and then just
scheduling and directions we wanted to
go don't let us to it to saying hey
separate projects is probably where it's
at okay and respect while we do it
nice um which is nice and tough you know
I feel like you know it hurts it hurts
but like it's it's a good thing and now
III split-off started making the Xbox
expansion pass something on xep I'm
proud of is that we take in the news of
the gamer verse we talk about
PlayStation we talking about Nintendo
but how it pertains to Xbox Live why
does it matter to us cuz it does what
does impacts us I mean that's why we
have game pass you know it just stuff
like that those conversations are you
and Real Talk it's the best thing in the
world is when I get to have interviews
I've had couple developers on to talk
about their games that's cool
had engineers from a company called
light stream which is if you do mixer
you've seen light stream mmm about their
technology in credible times and so I I
try to bring them in when I can but
really it's just about talking the Xbox
ecosystem and enjoying and celebrating
it in the gaming world goals you do a
fantastic job like I said be an addict
talked again soul old podcasting is very
difficult it's a different beast and
like
again with audio got a respective man
like I said we talked and you like you
know give me some feedback I might do
your baby like this boy got bars like
he's spinning and what I like it it's
your tone it's very professionally done
you have you guys are not subscribe if
you want something listen to something
on the road while you're moving and
grooving hit up X by Xbox expansion pass
really good I want to see super chat
real quick shout the Philly eagle with
the final super chat shout out to gaming
diversity he was like fun hashtag fun
happy and everyone in the room Oh would
you said oh oh he's got that back
welcomed he's up to silver no you know I
know what it is he heard that packs is
buddies I got a Sea King out there
eating the scrimps
no I do not say scraps I say sure but
you know I'm just being funny the deal
with itself
okay so embarrassing video back after I
had sold all that blood had to make
myself I had to make myself a name cuz
he that was Xbox Live's beginning for me
was was my next box 360 rolled around
and the hot game at the time was Ghost
Recon your McGraw remember bro right
what that's right so I'm like all right
I gotta be am ghosting people online I'm
taking am out doing my things okay and I
was watching the matrix and they say the
word insipid I'm like I don't know what
that means I googled it means like you
know dull uninteresting painful right
here let's go myself
well I'm ghosting people I don't care it
ain't nothing special it's so easy for
me I just do it whatever I'm not even
whatever so that was the nature of it
and then it turned out that like it's if
it goes it sounds cool to know what it
means
it sounds cool
why did he pick the blend glowstone
you're worried maybe in my 20s man I'll
tell you what boys they didn't happen
anymore taking me out left and right
break down real quick about the teaching
in and do you incorporate gaming and
stuff into that as well yes I do I real
talk to I wanted like I teach eighth
grade English right now and it's fat
with kiddos and cuz I love them I love
them I don't get paid enough but but my
wife helps me out on that one but real
talk like those kids are incredible
great man and whenever I can bring in
like if we need to analyze something
talk about something in class where talk
about tone and mood then I'm bringing in
titanfall trailers I'm pulling up a lot
of advertisements for ps4 or game pass
and I'm looking at all right what are
they trying to do what kind of message
are they trying to send you I love
bringing my hobby to their education if
it's practical and relevant because you
get so much more out of it when it's
real super $25 super chat Happy New Year
[ __ ] - the code daddy's the
homie and people don't realize
tremendous video game experience he's
actually one of our fun as guest like we
we had a ball with the Colbert we gotta
go back on but oh yes a little brother
thank you so much really means a lot to
us but all yeah listen man goes down
here spittin bars tremendous game
history love what you're doing man keep
it up but you know I gotta ask you the
question we ask all the guests in the
friend know that's coming you know that
top 5 Dead or Alive yours so let's get
to it go goes give me your top 5 video
game or franchises of all time no
particular order and if you have a zone
don't give a specific zelda all right
he could give specifics I think I know
what one of those specific Zelda's is
but we gonna leave that long it's not
like let's not make you go down a path
not a difficult as much topic as it once
was because we've had all these like
look back at the decades we really be
thinking about that stuff mm-hmm
real talk I do have to give due credit
to the witcher witcher 3 something
special that game was special that game
was special even if you have no interest
in the witcher that game is special and
if you do and you like fantasy cool
that's something there too if you
haven't checked out my Harry can recap
oh yeah man he did it he did it that boy
did it that's my Superman right oh don't
say that King you know he gonna cut you
off I'm listening actually he came back
to play Superman the warrior Brandon
Ralph - um shoe back on but you know
that's not about me just because I love
one doesn't mean I'm dissing the other
in that game real talk Arkham the Arkham
games what they did in the beginning -
all the way through night and night had
stumbles but if I could be frank with
you yeah that is my favorite Arkham game
it's not the best one but it's my
favorite because I spent the most time
in that world to have extra DLC with
story in that the best was galaxy gal
gallery rather of any hero yeah I love I
love that I need more and I'm mad at WB
we'll talk about that later like solve
do you get soft confirmation this is a
single play do you like Greg ghosts I
love I'll just say I'll take I'll take
the series I prefer Arkham Asylum is the
best one yet
Arkham City expanded on it in a way that
was very cool no I get what he says
about night it's just that tank stuff
that tank stuff short of it for me
plus your extra DLC the story stop was
very cool gameplay
Batgirl was very cool I get it and I am
tight with WBO what they're doing this
is ridiculous
halo man halo has has gone the ups and
the downs and recovered well I think
with that halo reach inclusion of Master
Chief collection hmm talk about recovery
which I might we're covering with
battlefront too man Master Chief
collection not in a band in that ship a
while ago and they really brought it
back love it so happy to see it people
should enjoy the world a halo the way I
get to it and I'm I don't feel I can see
I got the books no I do this I do the
novels the comics all that sighs what
about what I got I got to give you a
lord addict chin check real quick
what about wars are you are you a halo
do you follow the Lord you a weak low HP
ox action yes aatrox best villain in
Halo no all addict I'm addict is he
official now so dramatic mmm-hmm rising
aatrox a great comic if you've not read
it by the way yes and Real Talk 8 react
scared the Covenant you're telling me
we're not gonna have him in hate and
Halo infinite he better because halo
adores - they've already they've already
stated he's going to be an idol infinite
yeah did they really I missed that thank
you so much you got my day
halo Infinite is supposed to take place
like right after halo wars 2 is if you
get the legendary edition on Halo Wars
to Cortana shows off one of the
Guardians halo he gets in his back and
then he gets that Barry White voice yeah
well you know listen you got the co-star
for the single play oh shut up Tower one
hater
shout out shout out to you we media
starting there
you good - you look good if you got what
we got at Arkham Arkham Asylum
we got a Halo series right our code
Witcher Arkham halo what did we miss so
we missed something I got plenty I can
tell you about let's go
I'll give you years well give you dear
because gears is gears has evolved and
maintained true to what it was and
that's good in bed I understand why it's
losing people why it's gaining people
the gears are special to me because
that's what I sold the plasma to get to
got all those books and novels over them
I'm in and on on Halo and then lastly
its breadth of the wild the spread of
the wild gentlemen yes you are
solidified no sir I would since he's
brought up zeldo me spit me yeah going
me let me tell you something young you
much out of this class tell you about
breath the wild if at first you said
yourself man these weapons breaking
sucks yeah you're right but if you can
get over that which only takes an hour
till you figure out the game figure out
what it wants you to do realize that
cooking's not a chore man they weren't
lying when you said you could go
anywhere if you wanna walk up to the
castle and fight him I get rekt that's
not my game I get wrecked every two
seconds sometimes Nintendo brings a
magic that is just unborn it's just in
rutland and they did bring the magic
because they brought us breath a wild I
believe a year after Witcher 3 two very
different games in a fantasy world and
yet they're both fantastic
I prefer
spacesuits and heavy rifles and
badassery pardon my language sorry but
these guys make me enjoy using swords
and magic there are certain selections
in breath of the wild where you know a
four people that played like Fallout New
Vegas you know they direct you a certain
way or you'll get rekt yes they're like
look you got to take this road that's
the only way you need to take is you you
you to low level they're not even the
same thing at breasts in the wild
they're like look there's these
guardians up here the one shot you and
I'm like really not that you have one up
there's like can't go that way
you took a dock mode that's the
experience now I'll give you an
honorable mention what's height and fall
titanfall whoa I can fall two is ten
call one was incredible but it is
absolutely incredible underrated ei
screwed it over Vince Zampella
got his revenge let me tell you sure but
titanfall something special I think I
hope that comes back with titanfall 3 at
the right time when it's ready when it's
not gonna be consumed by a 48 other EA
titles in the same to happen again
you'll solve get the squirrel ease in
the building I asked where Lee's
temperature I said I lead an 82 it to
$10 if it's at your weekly report from
where the White Walkers be at minus 50
degrees Celsius talk about no no Game of
Thrones are we want to hear that minus
60 degrees Celsius is on the way in the
next few days a bring - 45 Celsius right
now
crushing MK 11 and witcher 3 and frost
punk say won't face our canadian bro man
as well
I told you doubt this smacking polar
bears temperature before it can avoid
squirrely gain in the bill I just got
cold shopping goes he's been killing it
with this phone I think everybody's
happy I'll be entire 42 as an honorable
mention or me respawn we can easily say
could arguably say has not made a bad
game since their existence not fencing
those guys Travon yeah huge huge list
man spots guys certify he's coming back
y'all he's coming back just cause it'll
is he's coming back anyway we gotta get
into the pole in the show lines go on
last week poll results are in and the
people have spoken to the question with
all the rumors of the ps5 reveal at CES
what do you think was the best possible
event for Sony to rebut the series
expert village at the game awards go
Molina of the three-way il people with
57% of the vote was the petit Lords I
don't carry a lot of who did death with
using a chair 34% of the vote was the
dedicated PlayStation 5 solely reveal
event group and in last place at only 8%
him was if CES is done right it could be
a huge splash group shout out to all the
lords are participating in degree Nord
King the realm thinks they cannot get
jiggy with nine teraflops at CES what do
you think about this
listen y'all could do all the smoke
screens on the sidestepping and we got a
teacher in here he's telling you
you can run from Microsoft the actual
Thanos gauntlet and if Sony got that
Walmart brand that one we put people in
position in your day going camp I told
you when we put the servers outside the
front of your house your sodas y'all
brought the azure cloud services inside
the building
yo CEOs be dropping like flies we've as
not alleged to let you we got another
play fair we got your uh no wait why buy
eggs at nine no no no you buy 12 dozen
eggs what do we stop you stop show the
what are we dragging it uber GOG no bill
do need oh well that's a good point man
no one wants nine they want 12
Oh get that nine out of here I want
every Saudi fan but will you buy a dozen
eggs I want you to take some of them out
you don't deserve all two very very very
dodgy Dodge night in there and 100 by
man man just got home I have to catch
the noise later tonight on replay wanted
to wait till the Lord's we're done to
tweet so y'all salut man much love to
the nlg gaming podcast believe Fridays
at 9:00 p.m. salute those brothers
Fastback stinger hdk all the crew you
already know so we go get into Topsail
okay we're gonna set it off with you
first
um lot of things going on in PlayStation
nation you're I'm saying so um yeah we
had C s it was a big debate last week
and whether what Sony should do what
they shouldn't do and we got something
revealed and we want to talk about that
as well as the future of window
we I guess think Sony is going to reveal
officially but people want so King the
floor is yours
oh wow super super yes shout to Smitty
Smith finished a known voice $10 even if
I like that failure Phil Spencer the
series X is inevitable so we gotta find
out a super track from triggerman Xbox
are stuck in the ultra combo with no
Colville break-in site X third
exclusivity back to even compete with it
it's in - let alone Sony I'm assuming
that no combo ultra combo thing is some
is some bed - head fire yes that's a
that went straight over my head man I'm
sorry this is good for you to see but we
don't need a combo break I'm glad you
said there is no common break in sight
and we actually we're performing the
ultra combo you know you catch the ultra
combo on your neck on that logo feel on
your chest
no I said they don't watch that I
purposely put myself in the camp of
PlayStation fans and I was watching a
YouTube guy he was live streaming and
his chat was going crazy they bout to do
it reveal it's going down your phone how
we felt but then it turned the faeces
thing is all like it was the wildest
thing I've ever seen I've never seen a
crowd revolt in such a manner but but
let's not forget why they were so upset
and why they were ready to revolt Rick
and it's Tony's fault
mmm it's so nice Paul first of all we
practically did you think real ps5 news
would come and see yes no until you find
out that Jim Ryan's gonna be there and
be on stage and then Cory bar logs will
be showing up and they didn't they
didn't set expectations after all they
told you so you told in correct and they
said what did you get King what did you
get a new car
we're gonna Tesla head to Sony was
trolling them it felt like Sony was
trolling their fans and throw that in
the bushes that was ridiculous this is
the greatest role of us this little
stage six minutes and gave you the logo
as said and dropped no he dropped the
mic on the logo leg like the interior
that car look bad - remember when I told
you to pull a Volkswagen but you know
what they did show you what the police
station fire was they didn't tell you
what was powering that car was ten
PlayStation fives at the bottom and they
can get you to the next destinations
that actually news like I swear in chat
help me out
I'm swear we saw the PS 5 logo when they
announced God fall
did we not and and correct my memory but
that didn't seem like news I didn't seem
like news that quote great they thought
it was new they thought it was news for
you to know that we got a new logo for
you they gave you vague like all the
stuff that they told you already there
was a SSD Drive they gave me very
controller stuff they gave everything
was what they did already
it was absolutely no need for any
PlayStation announced but any place they
shouldn't talk any PlayStation anything
to be present on that stage I thought it
and I just want to bring it to the pan
arm yeah enough with the jokes right
now this serious talk now yeah we have
seen different Sony's right and this is
a difference Tony huh I grew up on the
Sony that was the brave the both the
badge right I grew up on that Sonia I
brought a group on Tony that was so
aggressive that they went to Nintendo
headquarters and they had Crash
Bandicoot out in the soup and it was
looking at like a plumber plumber boy is
my question to you is this see a lot of
the Sony dudes thinking this is the same
old Sony is this the same old Sony
because this is looking mighty
unfamiliar and real recognize real and
they look at mighty phony right now like
how familiar to you right let's get to
it by me except you had a lot to say
goes you had lied to save represent but
you know I just well let you finish it
thought you know do you you think this
was a misstep do you think that do you
think that you kind of alluded like do
you think people set expectations too
high like where you at with logo gate so
to speak Oh Real Talk I think Sony has
caused themselves a misstep amongst
their there are more enthusiastic fans
and it's not gonna have major
repercussions people with gamers forgive
and forget very quickly yes there is no
doubt about that but they've not they
weren't at e3 probably a wise decision
giving context but they weren't of e3
there was no PSX they announced the PS 5
in a wired article they kind of faked
their fans out by saying Jim Ryan's
gonna be there Cory bar logs gonna be
there they faked their fans out in this
CES conference and in in 2019 not
something there weren't any real bangers
for that incredible Sony exclusive
lineup mm-hmm and that is probably all
Nikola not just real quick
tipping away at a very powerful and
righteously empowered Sony fandom which
now you're starting to Nick them and
death by a thousand cuts because you're
starting to give them less to argue
about and they were so high oh because
they did have an extra incredible
exclusive but it is it sounds like it is
they better bring out some serious
bangers and bring the fire when it's
for ps5 because right now all the
momentum is with fill Dominus Spencer go
an eight on them they threw out EXO 19
and was word open EXO 19 without the
series X then they brought the series X
in front of 42 million people at the
Game Awards and then all these Sony fans
were like oh but what about it's our
time it's in here because we see Jim
Ryan we see what they're gonna be doing
at this conference Cory bar lock and
then boom it's the logo and that logo
Falls real flat so Sony had better bring
the fire because Microsoft is firing on
all cylinders they're not holding back
they know it was exclusives that were
their downfall in this generation and
what did they do they've now got 15
Studios branded xbox game studios
branding games that are double-a
triple-a and indie all we have to
quality with the initiative who knows
what they're bringing and Sony has got
to step it up for their fans who are
there in droves for that catalog no
doubt shout-out to Maude's
your email telling us it would shatter 3
20 20 let's go let's go probably already
know log net in the building knows a
game with that that's old mods gaming
salut
let's get to it man little go gating
this whole stuff Oh Lord addict you're
up sir um we at man misstep where we
expecting too much you know where we at
what the oh yeah we would look at the
other day we weren't expecting too much
because they didn't give us an
expectation to really go off of like
it's the equivalent of you know we
expected when it came to when it came to
EXO okay fellas she's gonna be there we
expect some announcements because he's
gonna be that right they never came out
and openly told us anything so we
expected something no though you know
just just the presence of certain people
at certain events there phase are
automatically would expect bigger news
and if they don't keep those that you
know those expectations realistic it's
going to go out of the way right and
their doctor bitchin well they did get
out there they show us a logo and he
sounded so
I see he acted like he acted like like
it was it yo uh this is literally how I
saw him your we we got this new logo
it's a great new logo we put ours on and
it's literally the same no did anybody
savage did you see what they deleted
before nobody had the Adobe Friday
father they had the door first of all
salute we got some royalty in the rare
we got RDX royalty in the realm themself
over dancing and [ __ ] what's going on
guys to be on the show and man I just
learned some news today I got me super
hyped I wish I could share it with the
world but you know at the end of the day
just be excited man so it's a lot of a
very good stuff coming man they're all
tangled up in the damn core like you
know I'm I'm good to go man I'm good to
go quick before I forget shout to the
store Hades which awesome [ __ ] at the
most surprising thing about CES was a
new car so petty so bad but I'm gonna
get start off with you and then we go
alright to solve you know back to you
don't be a 5 logo gay you know what's
going on yeah when you when you steal
your logo off Google [ __ ] the thing was
arguing on Google for years right so I'm
sorry I'm sorry
um expectations were too high do you
think that people was thinking getting
trying to look at CS a little bit too
hard for this information
I mean is it can you blame him mm I mean
I was listening you guys earlier and
then I was like they did they didn't
tell everybody Corey's gonna be there
like yeah well leave what are they doing
well apparently nothing
everyone everyone when they thought Jim
Ryan was revealing the PlayStation
they're running up to the stage with
their little cell phones out get ready
to take the picture and then
nevermind go sit back down it's just a
logo where you at with this whole thing
why bother why even waste a breath on
mentioning it if this is what you're
gonna because the thing is you gotta
remember a lot of these consoles back in
the day they were announced at CES right
if you think about what CES right and
you think about fridges you think about
TVs whatever but it's the Consumer
Electronics Show for Sony what is the
biggest consumer electronic product they
have coming out in the following year
it's the play the play apparently the
car right playstation if if you decided
to come to play to to CES full force I
guarantee you it would it would have
been a big hit if they were sound like I
said last week make the PlayStation the
center of your presentation because
obviously you're damn near ready to
pronounce it anyway because I've heard
rumors already that invites are going
out for a February event like they did
with ps4 so it's they obviously almost
ready to talk about if it was announced
today like you know exactly the reveal
event will be this day like give give
people with something to look forward to
it doesn't make any sense and they could
have they could have taken over the
entire CES conversation with place with
real PlayStation 5 information on so I
think it's a miss Vegas a missed
opportunity it's a missed opportunity
why even bother bringing it up that mmm
you know I like like like go said though
I don't think in the long term is gonna
affect anything right people gonna be
excited to see it next month fine it's
just why why bother bringing it up don't
even do it yeah you know what went under
the radar
shout out to Phil Dominus Maximus
Mitchell sir the same day that they
supposed to do all this little reveal
and all this stuff this is what the
strategist does I'm at home I'm chilling
you got cake talk I don't you go
I'm in my house but you know while y'all
want to see something instead of a
stupid logo mm-hmm
check out the silicon any change in the
brick mmm and he lets you know what the
real do secrets right now you're seeing
real acting real my thing is take the
fanboy out just just step aside for a
second and just looking exactly what's
happening if you really look you can see
the fake happening right in front of you
and don't fall for a banana in the
tailpipe what you did was when they told
you core Ebola I thought god of War's
day was gonna show the VR right I
thought okay other aggressive Sony would
show you something that their competitor
can't do right is not in that space so
we can dance on the stage and take away
from there nine verses twelve stuff take
away from the narrative a power take
away the narrative the speed take away
all of that stuff that's in the book do
what we do best what they can't do what
we're doing so Cory Barling up there
with a little piece a little snippet
something with God of War VR some
something tiny Oh literally show a PNG
of God award yes but the next generation
PlayStation people would have gone crazy
we're gonna talk PC I thought he's gonna
say God or PC told the base though that
would right you think a PNG would be
enough but then they show all this
hell-blade stuff and then it's not
enough right it's not right they would
have to show more absolutely they would
have to show more any sake of fairness
it's like a fetish out the chief Tom
because I got a rep chief he I gotta
keep it fair on in like the logo went
viral it broke into the grizzle
so you know Sony nation is like look oh
you know we still out here look how
fever-pitch this is what do you say you
know what I say to this I said it is it
broke the internet because y'all fools
y'all y'all so trolled in that first of
all Calvin got ahold of that logo
it was the work
in the world it was just like for didn't
erased it and put the little five the
same five little fart like dealer said
it's been there done that but y'all
y'all thought that was cool
well oh you thought when you put likes
that was the get thumbs down right this
is what you thought because if Phil
woulda went up here and there's some
stupidity like that I think they would
have blue blue Marcus walked back to the
stone Age's if it feel when it came out
with just the series series X listen it
showed you a card I had nothing to do I
said and Xbox is doing cars xbox doesn't
show cars unless it has do it for just
commented on the retweet of you the
posts will be in there he says don't
forget to ask Lord addict Pokemon what's
going on there at it hold on we have a
few super test we need you so start out
to stitch 66 69 with the two dollar
super chat at King well it might be
called the Apple P as five states you
might be onto something set out to
restore Hades with the two dollars to
perch at the most liked picture on
Instagram is up an egg and of course we
have shout out to Wilma hood with the
9999 super chat likes equals teraflops
lol they got a million tariff laws and
shoutout to the triggerman with the $2
super jet with good to see Xbox fan boys
happy for one since he had a great time
on crossfire just just crushing people
it's funny will means amazing podcast
with more crossfire one time and also
saw your show the other night he's
fantastic man
so look I get I'll be jumping right
quick this is funny you know see
obviously the logo was submitted for
letdown you know saying of course you
don't saying so I guess for me it's like
I'm which you King like the hype was at
a fever pitch this super $15 gym riot
PlayStation logo pressure on you dude
that they had nothing to go but the logo
they say yo Calvin well we got ready so
I got a logo sir just not a trickster
anyway look I hear what you're saying
yeah now wrong I wish I already X right
now I listen to you guys this week
dealer and you guys made some fantastic
points and one thing is I guess the
thing I'm frustrated is okay
I didn't go too crazy with CES I just
thought it would be cool if they did
something as a rub but because we're not
used to seeing solely on the defensive
Microsoft seems with the series X has
been very aggressive which is what the
Xbox community want we love this right
he's dropping this information we're
getting bits and pieces of news bits and
just everything to kind of galvanized
the base prior to the launch so for Sony
we like okay what they gonna do cuz
historically during the PlayStation 4
generation they have been penny anytime
max I have a little bit of shine they'll
usually do something to kind of offset
that to make you remember yo who's the
big dog in New York kind of for this
generation so we didn't see it and then
we get the logo and it's like shotgun so
yeah of course you know people were
upset so I guess the thing where I kind
of I'm kind of disappointed overall
though is just the lack of presence
lately obviously no III know PSX you
know it's been a minute for like a
dedicated event now
obviously it looks like February most
likely look to be honest with you it
feels like it's been like a year and a
half I just miss the aggressive here
you're doing this year's e3 either
obviously if you look at it from a
standpoint to how they've been acting
this whole generation to this last year
and a half they were always responsive
Xbox do something they have something to
drop right afterwards remember when the
gears Metacritic scores popped up okay
gear gets cool we're gonna drop that
last was release state later on today
this week I want to transition right
into a do listen let's get a dealer cuz
um you know the rumors are out there now
we're hearing again you know shot the
package I love you but you know he's won
Geoff Keighley is another one the rumors
are you know that they are hearing that
Sony making new zoom in on that three
hundred percent he was like Sony doesn't
have to go hard my next Xbox Microsoft
has more to prove than Sony shout the
face as a fan no you shouldn't really
care you she'd always wanted to go hard
right let me find we don't need to hear
your opinion get him deal he was
slacking get a deal hurry up addict come
on we got a bog dollar super jet from
Philly ego
are you happy till I'm doing him super
question for the fanboys so I'm assuming
you know they're talking to me
how many gamers play numbers answer none
annalistic fan boys are stupid shut the
F up and late games here you really got
the bat one of nails in another day so
let's get to a deal I mean what are you
thinking do you think they can afford to
miss III they can because they still
want to e3 last year and weren't even
there I'm just kidding I'm just kidding
it was pretty rough man but my guy I
think Microsoft had a completely
different thing planned and they heard
Sony backing out like huh well we'll
hold it off mm-hmm
and that kind of bit him in the butt
when we watch the band be had but that
Xbox so kind of any machine right so it
just they got to do some things
differently this time around and yeah
that's a lot of people are saying that
and that's what we're hearing as well
like Sony are not going to go to e3 this
year mm well I mean question is what are
they gonna do they get there one of it
playing I'm guessing other than February
note that I think they should do more
before PS 5 comes out I'm not sure
nothing wrong no I go stood on this man
go say you bought these recent rumors
you know we're hearing Geoff Keighley
saying as of right now we don't think we
don't know if they're attending saying
they were my compactor whose track
records but a little spotty little
spotty goes like can they afford to go
to e threes when I or is it no big deal
is it just a three is just not what used
to be III is not what it used to be and
that's okay that's okay they can afford
to sit set again because the reality is
when you're vying for those headlines
when you're fighting for that time and
you might get you know 10 minutes versus
hours on end from having your own
conference I think there is something to
that not to mention we've got to be real
here three has been dwindling in it and
it's important thanks to digital
distribution and digital messaging
moreover they had that big ol ESA leak
that's putting a lot of people out of
remorse their Microsoft doesn't need to
skip because I got them and then they
can officially skip but I got the
Microsoft theater right there they can
do their own thing that is there
that is their error area their territory
they can have their own thing whether
it's III official or not EA has long
since left there's a diminished presence
because floor space is expensive why
spend forty million dollars to get your
message out when you can do it for
cheaper and more directly Nintendo
taught us this Microsoft's got the means
to deal with their own theater and I
think Microsoft are sorry pardon me
stony can indeed skip mmm III and the
world will be just fine I got a what
have them yeah reason why I got a
rebuttal for that because this 7u is
that a III use a fan fest' right so you
never oh yes yes sir right so you
understand the importance of catering to
your fan base or cating to a base period
when you inside that hall and you have
you been to pass III s nothing I'm sorry
yeah now that was my first one all right
so you that's your first III I've been
to pass series and when I got to the
hall it was a gaping hole right now you
had some PlayStation VR stuff that was
there and then you have some stragglers
that are in the Sony camp that had to
show their games but without the big
corporate backing without the big logo
behind you for her logo behind you
pushing you forward push you in the
limelight they kind of fell flat right
and Nintendo never skips III maybe they
don't do a presentation but Nintendo's
e3 presence is felt foot on your neck
it's true that's true
alright so and you said Microsoft has
the Microsoft theater where they had
everybody sequestered over there it's
not paying for floor space now you just
brought paying for four space costs a
lot of money but if the market leader
shouldn't money not be an object for you
to show off your wares I really believe
that they skipped it because it had
nothing to show but a logo so they have
nothing to show they had desk old sizzle
reel that they would have brought up and
it would have fell flat
they knew Microsoft was coming with some
bigger guns maybe III didn't feel good
for certain people but Microsoft I
showed you was a slow burn moving
forward my thing is
three is essential to the community to
keep the community growing forward you
know yes it's changed once they allow
the public inside but don't you want as
many public eyes on top of your software
and hardware as possible going forward
isn't that a thing why are we acting
like it's okay I'm gonna show something
in the closet a post or something and
open that people can touch and play it
and enjoy okay let me spit this at you
and and this is what I think is likely
or more likely at this time based on
what we know I would love to see PSX
happen just like fan fest happened yes
what what happened when they did their
big old conference what they do they
took all of us that were at fan fest
that had the energy the enthusiasts
those fans are talking about we went in
the room and we brought it energy we
brought the fire because we were excited
to be there whether the news were
bombshells are not those people were
happy to be there what if there was a
PSX at this time and it wasn't at you
know it wasn't Sony e3 but it was so
many three simultaneously with Sony
doing their own thing separately near
the site where they're not having to
deal with ESA where they're not how they
can control their entire messaging on
their own is that something that's more
likely or relevant for you I would hope
so but as they shown that they have
dropped EXO on PlayStation of Dane
little not even a fan fest thing they
stopped that they stopped giving they
give to you a little PlayStation play
things every once in a while say yes but
it's just the fact that they have a darf
when it comes to their triple-a Bangerz
they're not really release of stuff they
hold it on to go Tsushima and I really
believe that's going to be a cross
generation to title when the PlayStation
5 comes out then you look like trash
right supposed to hold them back right
dealer if you're making a console or to
the lowest basic denominator which is
the PlayStation base system that is
supposed to run on that it should hold
them back right why and that's why god
paul looks better than anything ever
made this one is gamer forte access
movement bringing the energy
I wanted this Jenner entire generation
Sony better not get comfortable because
Xbox is playing for keeps
Jonathan B Sony isn't at any events
because they spent all their money on
soda bottles cause who wanna get a JD
game I saw a GTA game you know long one
second JD game with the $10 super chat
dealer plus panel Sony's not showing up
because they lack the exclusive content
that they have promised we'll be
showcasing at e3 I eat right now and I'm
stick to this right now you can document
it or any podcast when you go to put
your discs inside swipe your credit card
to the left a built-in courier see them
giving you anything for free if they're
penny pinching now what makes you think
they're gonna open up the coffers for
you
oh I tried to grab the gun already but
bro look we gotta see this is this is a
big thing I would be disappointed if
they don't go eat I mean we go to III
double console launch would be awesome
you know I'm saying just to have to be
both they're competing and forget about
the console or that stuff as a Sony fan
right this you like you would love to
see them there you would you would love
to see them give to their base to get
them galvanized excited not saying that
the reveal is not we know when they do
the reveal if it's February March people
gonna be high if people gonna that the
base will be excited but it's almost
like a continuation of the news cycle
and why not when there's that many eyes
and I do hear your point goes goes
you're making valley III is not what it
used to be right also we do know those
leaks have hurt media types big-time ESA
is in big trouble right now especially
you know leaking anybody business out so
that's gonna get people a little more
reluctant to come out this year but we
know Microsoft's gonna be there you know
Nintendo is gonna be there it's a new
console launch I think it would still be
a mistake to not go now if you want to
talk about the Future III after and say
III missed is losing relevance and maybe
after that they'll reevaluate but this
particular one without PlayStation 5
console ports you want to get people
galvanized I'll leave it to y'all before
you move on anybody else sad I wouldn't
wanna say real quick I'm not rooting
against them to not be that or be there
I'm saying the world is not called
crumble yeah and as long as Sony does
right by their fans by the fans of
gaming give us a reason why why we need
to be there in on day one I just want
them right by their fans don't care
where it happens mmm-hmm microts B III
but if it's not I'm not gonna lose it no
you know you're not gonna be surprised
right
Lord addict would he get JD gamers on
super chat before war yeah so we got a
$10 super chair from JD gamer
Diller plus the panel Sony night
[Applause]
guess she was thirsty gotta find out
super chat from JD gamer Saudia spoke to
Sleeping Bear Microsoft and the bear has
responded by biting their button off and
LPS can't even take a seat anymore
hashtag it's over so it's it's over for
so Haiti got the numb trucks out today
we got to get this going man this is why
a lot of people are here they wanted to
hear the Lord's opinion of your topic
hot off the press what is going on in
the world of Series X first let me
apologize to the realm foot for bringing
this fake news to the realm fake news
you know you know every now every now
and again we have to we have to address
things like this in an interview with
MTV UK head of studios at Microsoft head
of Studios Xbox Studios headers do you
Matt booty indicated that they want all
of their games particularly for the
first two years of the life of the Xbox
series X to play literally the quote is
all of our games to play up and down
that family of devices in basically
indicating the Xbox Series X won't have
any exclusive games for its first year
or two that will not also appear on the
X and the S and of course the internet
got into a tizzy over there ah
what do you guys to you know what I
think I call the fake news because they
said this a long time ago right Phil
said a long time ago we're we're talking
about playing across generation yeah
this is an obvious thing particularly
for the first couple of years of a new
console site by all accounts the SHA day
sold very well over this holiday so what
do you tell to a shoddy owner that all
of a sudden turns around you tell them
well no you can't have any of these
games
in a year last of the year after you
picked up that counts oh not a
consumer-friendly thing to do and the
fact of the matter is the moment they
made Xbox game past the focus of their
ecosystem they were telling you with
that move that what matters to them is
playing the games wherever you want to
play them okay and they're going now
that to ride especially on the console
side for as long as they can I'm saying
we got that we got we got the guns in
here we got dealer here we got the ghost
in here you don't simple we got to paint
this fish you know I'm saying because at
the end of the day you know a shower
coat is already on VC Devco I was gonna
say your point you already put it in
superjet all right cool file I switch
this is not fake news catering to the
old hardware does indeed hold back game
design don't know why this is so
difficult for people to understand and
then one bad mother-- find out a search
at number one thing that holds games
back is budget now tech Xbox one cloud
and PC gamers equal holds more but
equals more budget so I want to focus on
what code said because this is the
opposing thought right now Twitter is on
fire people are saying as a result of
Microsoft doing this that the next
generation is being held back they won't
get there the optimum performance and
unlike PS 5 which has announced god for
which is also a pc by the way but it's
gonna be I gotta throw it out but I
don't but you know people feel that
Sony's approach it's a get on exclusive
content and next-gen games only on that
is is a different approach that they
prefer so they can maximize the
potential of said hallways so let's get
the guest in here first let's start off
wait I want to start with going through
I'm not dealing we I know we gonna go in
but I want to start with ghosts first
where you at with this first as it is is
not news we've heard for compatibility
back compatibility from phone or Spencer
for so long for so long and real talk
this is a different generation I am so
okay
with cross-generational titles because
I'm excited to play infinite on the Xbox
series X with the latest and greatest
graphics power on my 4k TV
that's a premium buy-in for me I'm
choosing to aerate my fan I'm sorry my
funds to my fandom that's what I want to
do but I do not want some of my best
friends who can't do that won't do that
aren't ready to do that
I don't want to pay gate them out in the
best games with me ah Forza horizon for
I play control with the ray tracing and
the goodness on my ex my smile on X our
friends are playing it on s that's not
hurting me that's helping me cuz it's
there in the ecosystem I'll brighten
that I'm excited for that hmm
I recognize that the counter-argument it
could be holding people back but it's
just not that way anymore guys are you
are you inferring something about game
design has changed
it definitely has absolutely not in
Gears of War 5 on my phone because of X
cloud it's not native but it works and
that means I can have fun with something
that looks beautiful on pixel there's no
reason to say that tech can't take
people's experiences with the SHA day as
you say box 1x and they play via cloud
they play the latest and greatest that
way I don't want my friends pay gaited
out of the best experiences because I
want to invest in local hardware their
game e has changed it has I don't want
that exclusive title for that first two
years and just like our iterative
devices we're gonna have to scale up at
some point
hmm because it can't hold things back
but that's fine that's ok goodness
gracious
is this JD super champion um remember
the last gen Microsoft remember last gen
Microsoft well Sony has decided to dance
let me take these shoes out there we go
ok not spending money crazy executive
moves secret sauce is this the new
PlayStation they're screwed right did
you make in Lewis I got a chrome does a
1080 1080 hold back a 20
and that is my argument with what code
said right so if you if that's your
argument right then at every level of
development something is holding
something back even on the PC side
because if that's the case then why
don't people make the argument well why
aren't PC games maybe at the top tier
they've made or twenty atti with this
much RAM and then everything else below
that is holding back the ability of are
you implying that this has been going on
in the PC ecosystem how games are made
that the entire platform is based on the
scalability what's what's those games
are made just for a 20 minute I look to
your left and watch the entire industry
go under because it stained by merely
the top and stuff nice free strange I
just want to point something else out to
know that a lot of people aren't talking
about somebody mention game design and
that's a good point you said it yourself
game design who's designing games any
differently right now nobody when you're
talking about games being built just for
an SSD what does that mean I can't use
an external drive no longer there are
restrictions to every single facet of
every single form of innovation regard
regarding game design right you're also
going to add to the fact that for the
first time ever you were going from x86
on console to x86 on console Bryton
so you were talking about it right from
the get-go your games port easier things
are easier to implement and innovate or
maybe everyone right when you're talking
about game core this is for
next-generation consoles only apparently
and they're going to be using that to
help along with of course I'm sure
similar difficut like the Xbox one extra
you get everything in one box and you
can code from Warren boom hit another
button and hidden Copa next right but
when it comes down to it at the bare
minimum at the very bottom God fall is
made for the PS 5 not the ps4 yeah you
would have to be something's wrong you
got some cataracts something wrong on
there if you look at that game and tell
me it looks even close to halo infinite
now both of their trailers we're running
in real-time at 60fps and that's why I
compare those two because they're both
targeting the same frame rate only one
of them and let's turn it around on them
was made for say it with me
1.3 T flops now which one looks better
right now there that's not really my
point is a semi last video both of those
games will look better infinite is
confirmed to be having rate racing stuff
like that as well it will look better
when it comes out people that question
that question the same thing with gears
you just won't look that good when it
comes out well know where to look
they're good uncounseled for one the X
ain't even a shadow of what the Sirius X
will be and it still looked that good on
the X right right so let's not forget
that either but look but I agree with
the logic and I've been pushing this on
RDX and the videos the scalability is
the name of the game going forward the
industry cannot be sustained by the top
and models merely and there's more to
that it's not being held back like a lot
of people think it's a lot of needless
fear-mongering based off of almost no
information regarding what we've seen
going forward I don't Nate I think
there'll be crossing games that look
better than only next-gen only games I
think that's how skill buddy has
improved man appears keys are tight to
play on PC and talk about how things
look so much better there then the base
Xbox one you are our testament to that
you got some super chests we got a hit
alright let's get the old optimus cold
one five okay even with all that solved
as said there's no reason that they
can't make one title that showcases
hardware so he's not feeling that we're
gonna get that year quote-unquote buff
for a transition but that's you you I
mean they've come out and said that
their focus is Halo Infinite and in all
likelihood for the you know seven so
it's whatever they're building those
beginnings to be focused and on on on
showcasing the power of the series X and
then they scale down from there right
Judy said that I'm sorry Judy said that
he said that they were gonna push some
games with the features to show off the
hardware that's that's fantastic and
similarly it's not my job to worry that
Microsoft makes money selling this new
console that's my job is to enjoy and
celebrate games as I like but none of us
need to go out there worried about with
this billion dollar trillion our
corporation does we didn't buy games how
we like to play games and they're giving
us option to giving us good cost catalog
and choice that's how you do it
I do want to saw I do want to say
something else for real it's not never
the same people that are talking about
all this holding stuff back and this and
that they're the same people to point
out how Microsoft drops support for the
original Xbox so quick and complain
about it right and same exact people
secondly it across this stuff that
happens every generation third every
single game is gonna look better on the
series x over to PS 5 now you might have
we all know the recent Naughty Dog stuff
so near Santa Monica stuff looks so good
it's art direction our design detail
comes from time and development not
necessarily one or two people it comes
from the time they give their teams
which is something Bill Spencer's been
talking about right the art direction is
big here that's why a rare game looks
like a rare game you think they couldn't
make a game that looks better
of course they could they chose to look
it and make it look that way so it's all
about the direction they're trying to go
and of course the time they put into
that stuff my point is if you're really
gonna talk about things being held back
by your own logic no third party game
ever has ever leveraged any hardware
ever because it was made or another
device so so ragnarok sasser's be
Ragnarok well the biggest games of this
year mm-hmm what's a goodly best one
right PC and Series X that will never
change
let's get these super chairs man we got
a lot of stuff to talk about no one
really knows shots restored Haiti's
final switch shot no one really knows
what Sony's gonna do Microsoft can
easily hire somebody to make an
exclusive game it doesn't have to be a
first party studio chief Tommy two hours
to reach at what a lot of hearts in love
so who wants to get faced 23 Xbox game
studios heard Matt booty has said that
Sony has done a fantastic job across the
board degeneration and he doesn't really
see Microsoft engaging in a head-to-head
bout with Sony I think that literally
was a some articles I saw coming on you
know in price and you know what you know
what's funny a lot of these articles and
stuff I see like they're quoting
something happen at Excel like some of
these interviews happen to EXO now
people were making arts as I mean the
big news of Moody's most recent
interview was the fact that he did
actually give a timeline for the cross
room for yes he said one maybe two years
and that was never said before we got a
$10 super chair from
a sqd I'm assuming that's how you want
me to say that game 8th one I will
pronounce however it do you want to read
the super check these people that don't
have the right info all games will be
scalable similar to how PC games are now
it will not hurt the series X by
supporting the old gent at the current
time all right let me get the cold let
me get the coal real quick hold on I got
you cake yeah no no no I LP
that's if we are only talking about
graphics and graphics card there's more
to it than that so scold still don't
agree and who are getting a JD gamer
files with JD gaming with the final of
super chat sadhana stepped in and made
it clear that the excess the Xbox or not
suffered because of the OG xbox one
development is done Co P down the lower
model suffers time down the door model
suffers alright he might even invite you
can fatalism power the last one yeah
swirly swirly there okay well we about
braaap with the two dollar super chat
all I have to say is III 2020 let's go
and PC Mac oh I know prep is a I want
you to say PC master-race when that PC
gaming show takes off but let's go keep
going argument nautical about that that
2070 versus 1080 ti 1080 CI liter 2070
of the dust son I saw somebody on my
timeline I'm not gonna give you a light
of day real quick but King let's get rid
of a cold who needs the invite we'll be
working on that core ethical Scooby Dan
82 with the five dollar Canadian dollar
super chat can I can one game get made
and when you noted it did the game one
laid the game asks what hardware do you
have then load files a for new gen and
files B for old gen whoa
we sort of had that happen to live right
where you had a notable part I remember
shadow of war had the 4k texture pack
that you didn't have to download if you
didn't want to but obviously we had the
X you would download it so that option
has been there I don't think it'll be
that binary sort of
pick one pick a or b I think it'll just
it'll download whatever year are you
guys noticing how brainwash a lot of
these are fanboys are when it's okay to
say yeah let's leave that last
generation behind
I saw one point can say you know this is
one counterproductive to Sony's fake
messaging right
the fake messaging is they're telling
you that all the PlayStation 5 is gonna
be the end-all be-all PlayStation system
order which will allow you to play all
these backwardly compatible games right
this is what I'm telling you back with
compatibility with these guys is a lie
because they told you that this dot form
and they using God fall as the benchmark
right apparently these are these these
are the Talking Heads and these are the
talk of course I'm going to use your
words against you right now you told me
that God fall is available for
PlayStation 5 and PC one that's not
exclusive that hurts you again okay that
hurts you and you know who I'm talking
to him not giving you the light of date
it hurts you because I told you I don't
care I will play it on PC then hurt your
feelings it hurts you know and I will
play it at a higher fidelity because I
have a better card hu alright now we're
going backwards now let's let's say it's
only there what happens to that
PlayStation 4 do let what happened to
Tommy who just who couldn't afford who
gave his blood
you gave your blood and you got yourself
a PlayStation 4 and you wanted to play
God for because they told you back a pet
it's gonna happen and it's you gotta
give just a little bit more could you
give a kidney to get this PlayStation 5
the plate is God fall and you just
didn't have that kidney to give you
understand so pause to play God for and
you can't go back but see you know what
Microsoft said this maybe that ecosystem
is it for you because Microsoft say hey
you know that OG xbox that dudes laugh
that that came with the Kinect in the
box
mmm-hmm we're gonna hold you to him I do
mmm
you know if you got the gamepad
you don't have the bread right now no
more blood given Microsoft said no more
feeding vampires if you in the Box you
here with us I mean you're gonna ride
this out for two years we don't give you
two years to get your money together so
you can get this X and you can get this
lock card you can step your game up but
we're gonna give you time to marinate
while we cook these games over here for
this we're gonna allow you to catch up
we're not gonna leave you in the dust no
man left behind how do you feel if you
are on a cruise ship and you got left
and you guys a champion as bs sony
dropped support for the ps4 so quick
happened one fell swoop yeah I'll get it
let's get it yeah so alright so let's
get to it basically what this sounds
like is philosophies right this is two
companies apparently having a philosophy
Microsoft is saying and they've been
said shout the ghost you've been on the
money with this you know forward
backward compatibility bringing the
ecosystem they want you in the ecosystem
a corner where booty is saying he is
like look we want people to invest in us
and not feel like they're going to be
left behind and we'll have you know
we're probably rock out for another year
or two right before there's a cut-off
because ultimately there will be a cut
off just like iPhones or anything else
right there's gonna be a point where the
high end is going to have features and
functionality that the lowest and lowest
common denominator cannot do and that is
the point and then the other thing is
obviously what dealer's saying is terms
of scalability in terms of the way the
PC market has been working for so long
you know I'm saying with high-end
features that we we anybody we're
telling you to knows that halo Infinite
is going to be the superior version on
the Xbox Series X but the
counter-argument now just for fairness
for Playstations they're gonna say look
they're the console business right they
want to sell consoles Bom
Jim Ryun has come out and said
explicitly we want to transition guys
over to the PS 5 as quickly as possible
right that is seems to
again this literally just seems like a
whole philosophy difference and I guess
the question I want to bring it back to
you guys is that you know is Sony wrong
for adopting that because in fairness to
Sony
they've been dominated the last
generation with said strategy so to
speak
I know ps4 did have a couple of ps4 only
child there were third-party stuff of
course you don't say that was cross
generational but they were a couple so I
want to go back to deal like you know
because the strategies work for them is
it okay for them they adapt that or do
you think they ultimately will have to
get in pocket what Microsoft is doing
with cross generational support now I I
am for whatever is most beneficial to me
right so if I can go and load up a game
on X Y or Z and in the scales properly
and it looks amazing you know I've heard
before of course that God falls may buy
a smaller team versus three for three
but at the same time you know does that
prove your improve the point again that
there are more than one factor here it's
more than is it just available on one
platform versus several or two versus
several there are so many different
factors here that determine how a game
looks how it turns out and how it runs
and that's really you can't really judge
how you can't really see you can't
really guess accurately at that until
you see it and and I'm joint is the
people are too focused on this rather
than what the games are gonna look like
or what they're really gonna play like
in front of you and that's their
ultimate we're gonna have to wait on and
that's part of the biggest problem of
Twitter it happened with the Scorpio
everyone fear-mongering that I don't
want that and I happened with Xcode I
don't I don't want that we're gonna be
held back is gonna overtake everything
streaming is gonna no more local
hardware and then it's happening with
the series X now we're Microsoft doing
the same thing they've done every
generation you know guess what games
will continue to run on this or that now
the difference is they're not locking
out certain first party for only
next-gen stuff because they've got all
of this you WP and scalability built in
the things to where they can scale
easier than they used to it's a
different thing now things are different
now there's no arguing against it right
hmm but also given ours there are no
mandates stopping third parties from
going nationally there are zero mandates
in fact the only mandate that I know of
is that if you develop for one next-gen
Xbox you have to develop for the other
ones so the Lockhart in the series X you
have to make it for both but there isn't
one for a developer saying you had to
make one for Xbox one games if you're
gonna make it for the next Xbox so you
may see third-party next-gen only games
that leverage that hardware if that's
Sara logic to the most if that's really
the way they want to go
but again the PC ecosystem all that
scalability things are just a bit
different now and I think people are in
a bit of a rush to kind of jump on the
negative not understanding and they did
this when we told him about the 12t
flops the day that Windows central and I
were talking about this [ __ ] nobody
believed us we were all crazy then
eventually digital foundry started
saying it and now you guys are gonna see
yourselves they hit the target then
that's the power and you know what at
the end of the day every single game is
gonna look absolutely insane on this
thing like that's all people need to
focus on we had some intense discussions
about this we're going at it you know
and you made some valid points obviously
I makes a better point we even spoke to
some developer friends of ours all seems
to battle each other but whose point was
right we go to expose said developer but
of Eggman you know when this news came
out initially you were disappointed so I
gotta get you in man let's get to it
brother like where you at with this you
know cross-generational for series X
supposedly having no exclusive alright
so I'm gonna count me peoples in here
one and okay how many people is on my
side one so I'm gonna fall back put that
point us we got to be we gotta be fake
about because last time I checked you
told me I don't have a 4k TV so I don't
need to go get that X because you told
me that you didn't have to jump because
necessary because the games worked on
the ass right so I can literally have
that same mentality with the series
accent wait two years am I gonna do that
no because I want to play Halo infinite
yeah but let's be real here King I have
an S Moto X money I saved from not
buying the X I could easily get flying
we used to play pub G I used to have the
puddle buildings yesterday and I was
told you the issues I had played that
with kids like it's like I said I'm
gonna say this and I'm not you could you
guys can Roberto I'm Tony right now the
moment I say this my mic is being muted
every time I say I'm disappointed look
do you know I agree with everything you
said you know what let's go he agrees
with you he said foul super chat so much
misunderstanding about how game
development works especially from those
with zero experience with development
experience cuz you know what you know
what your Brad Dobrev and I I do I do
have to say this about to miss Coco me
on but his cold point and your point
right let me give you a side so they'll
be not by yourself you guys are saying
to the letter of the law from a
technical standpoint if there is no
common denominator and the developer
only gets to focus on series X hardware
that there is a bit more performance
that can be pushed out so to my
disappointment is that by support I
don't even get that the law comedy
narrative
they won't reach that the most maximum
ceiling closed when I talk to our deaf
friend he said there are limitations but
it's not as drastic as people think he
said that for the mutations what were
the reasons we're not going in that
because we don't want to expose the
person that we talked about but he said
that the way development works right now
mm-hmm
there there's not as many limitations
because they always develop with those
with those availables in mind now you
said if they develop with just the
highest you know tear possible
the whole industry go out of business
because you got 5% of people buying this
before Diller even came on the board at
the end of the day he said yes if you
only develop for the highest concerts
you probably would have an elevation
what stuff looks like but the problem is
no one will be in business to see the
game shout to bribe the final super
chair the industry is large enough where
we where we see different approaches
that allow companies to be successful
whether you're the market leader or not
and that's absolutely true I don't if so
many continues to do things as both
console manufacturers have done first
forever right because my last gen
Microsoft launched it rise Dead Rising 3
you know what is it Crimson Dragon it
was like three local cycle both of them
had console exclusives isn't it so
I'll go ahead and you know I'll say
exactly what the person told me I'm not
gonna say his name I'm not gonna say his
name but I said you know I told my
scenario totemo was going on Twitter and
he said yes there are definitely some
restrictions that having to account for
multiple platforms or cards put on
development some aspects can be skilled
but not all it doesn't necessarily hold
back creativity but it's always nice to
have more horsepower to do the things
that you want you've got two variable
checkpoints you need to make sure you
plans line up and it's not just Hardware
your network business models have to
work
as well okay and then and then in in
defense y'all because even though I'm
not falling inside but I gotta be fair
you know there was an article that was
brought to my attention on pls guys from
twin finit and they talked about five
games in particular where this example
happened right one was destiny too you
know I'm saying and they talked about
how they felt the Cosmodrome could have
been a little bit better but they said
in order to get the games on total work
they had to make certain areas adjacent
to each others so that large objects
would be placed purposely so that the
lower PlayStation 3 and the Xbox 360
wouldn't have significant frame-drops
now too yada-yada division was on the
list The Witcher 3 was on the list and I
believe Crysis 2 so there have been
examples right of this people are saying
this again so the people are saying you
know why they just want it only on the
Xbox series X again I get the point to
the letter of the law I understand it's
a point where I'm going back and give it
to you guys I know you chomping at the
bit i'ma get you in a minute mom
it's just that from a practicality
standpoint and what our person that
attic has been speaking to is why they
don't do it is because again like the PC
gaming scrubs culture the PC gaming
scope they're not going to eliminate
these entire banks and there are still
things that are scalable you don't say
so that's pretty much the gist of it
ghosts you jump in and I'll get deal and
everybody else coming back in well I
just wanted to offer a bit let's step
back for some perspective and I think in
a couple aspects first its Matt booty
talking about exclusive studios that are
in their realm that they are working
with they are gonna have cross
generational stuff that is not to say
certain others cannot you know go with
just next-gen stuff I believe dealer was
alluding to that at one point I also
want to point out that one of the
benefits of console gaming is that you
have a status quo amidst your devices
and that has been bucked in trend
because we have ps4 launch ps4 slim it
for pro we have Xbox one module across
the way the way you just said that's how
I feel about control so I respect that
and we do have to have some perspective
there because it does put some pressure
on developers and in particular cases
because they have to let it work on the
Xbox won't watch all the way to the X
and that's a huge power difference you
can argue teraflops all day in the mouth
but if something is difficult to code
for or E or you have to scale at certain
a ton certain ways that can be more
stress on different aspects so I just
wanted us to back off a bit and
recognize that and then realize also
when Jim Ryan was talking about his we
want to get people to ps5 as fast as
possible well I understand that because
they've got double the install base that
Microsoft has to deal with 106 people on
with 106 million people trying to get
every single one of those people to come
over
it would certainly love it and they're
not stupid they're going to offer some
cross-generational aspects ghosts I
think looks like that to be the case and
the way that we transition people now
Microsoft doesn't need to to operate in
the same aspects because of the way X
out is they even said X cloud
it just works you don't even do anything
special for it so it it just I don't
want us to hit the panic button and
devolve into this shouting match amidst
the internet not us here but there's
more and more to it and it's a simpler
argument by accident when we make it
very complex let me ask you just goes
before I give a Dilla you know we talked
about the philosophy change right so you
know and what King King is making a good
point King is saying it's foolish for
gamers to sit there and eliminate a
whole generation of gamers just so that
they can have their chests out and say
this limited group right and let's be
honest from a practicality and a
financial standpoint the Delft devs not
gonna make money if the bigger base does
not have access to the game yes and and
if I didn't make it clear I'm with King
on that I'm on his I'm his perspective
in his mode there because I want
developers making money because
developers making money make more games
for me mm-hmm you know your developers
Dinah
I'm not playing game if they go ahead
I'm sorry at the end of the day it's
like I said you know I me myself it's
it's it's a me thing I personally would
I go buy a console and that's what it is
it's
nobody to have you see when I see go up
to and I get a console I do kind of want
you know games that's only for that
cause that's just me when it comes down
to let's be realistic in terms even if
there was at the beginning of the
gentleman he was there maybe five for a
whole year like that they don't really
have too many exclusive next year I
remember at the beginning of this
generation when they did when a third
party studio made a an exclusive game
that's dedicated just to the Xbox one
and the ps4 like it was a big deal so
like at the end of the day it's not a
big deal because there's not many of
them and by the time they had that cut
off and I think one of the biggest
reasons that Microsoft's not doing it
all the studios are accounted for
they're already making games so some of
the studios that that that obviously are
making that those games for the C's X
they're definitely not gonna be done so
they're not gonna be ready we're about
you to add it what about if people say
so you're okay with excluding a whole
millions of people not to play the game
that you like so you're cool with
millions so you rather have a smaller
halo infinite multiplayer Lobby you have
a very simple equal to just the series X
cool halo I'm as cool as that of doing
that just like you guys are cool with me
playing on generic stuff because I don't
want to upgrade to a console I miss
course who you guys are okay with
Microsoft downgrading stuff to where I
can't hide on stuff that's clearly in
the game because I'm on the lesser
sister you want that 10 player go yeah
multi player lobby are the only place
with people that have the same graphics
cards as him too
at the end of the day like I when I
picked up the gang system like nine
times out of ten people in this part at
this podcast you could say you didn't
but when you bought that that that next
step that Xbox one or that ps4 what was
the first game you put in that system it
was an exclusive that was out for that
system okay but you're the exception you
were gonna tell me it's like I talked to
kid I was like what's the first he said
rise the first game I put in was dead
Dead Rising 3 the majority of people
play that game they've won the head in
their mind that's the first thing they
put in that system and then tube TVs -
probably back there's the diversion
right there at the end of the day when
it comes to it you know I highly doubt
there's gonna be any good thing on
PlayStation coming out the gate anyway
but it's just like I would have
preferred a couple you know those games
it doesn't even have to be Haven I would
have preferred it like right now going
into this year I love the games they're
coming on but before I give it there
because everybody's ready to kill you
but before we do that we have before we
we have a forward our boy but what about
what about Matt booties comments about
focusing on particular games he said
Halo infinite specifically where they
are going to maximum are they're gonna
do their best to maximize the most
graphically so you see this series X
difference does that not give you any
confidence that series X version of Halo
Infinite will be far superior than the X
or the S or Lockhart or whether I mean
it's you could throw you could put a
rock on top of that I'd be running
better than this s so you know I'm
assuming it's gonna be I hope so you
know I would 88% chance it's gonna run
probably quadruple as best as his ass
and that's cool like you know that's a
cool little incentive to pick up that
console it's like when people buy the
PlayStation but you know ps4 gonna do it
if I go do the same thing okay
you know these ps4 games
you know last of us is gonna be enhanced
gosu Kashima is gonna be enhanced but
they're also gonna be like but we got
these games just for this console - yo
shout out to Mike Larry Philly Eagle in
your neck they said if Microsoft thought
like addict they'd be broke this isn't
no this is up at every generation
forward kind of new is the difference
right because everybody keeps comparing
apples and oranges you keep saying that
you know ghost of Ashima
is going to look the same on a plate oh
well grater on the PlayStation 5 then it
would look on the PlayStation 4 if
there's a cross-generational title right
all right everybody's forgetting the
caveat here right the caveat is game
pass right yes thank you so you have the
caveat which is game passed that gives
you the inclusion you this is like a
blanket it's a blink where you get a
blanky you say are you saying I'm cold
because I have lack of exclusive let's
go a blanket to warm myself up kid nexif
I snuggled up you warm
I'll let the blankie you feeling good
right because you're in good hands now
right now better be a good hands man
I've never started a fire I don't know
how to do that I want you to understand
something right this is the difference
is the difference let's say you don't
decide to scale up let's say you just
had to stay nice and warm in your
blanket right and you have your s or you
have a regular right and I have this
series X now what you're missing out on
is the retracing 60 frames per second 4k
that I'm using on my television let's
say you didn't upgrade yet right and you
don't have a 4k television let's say
you brought your the Black Friday guy
and you go always getting Black Friday
deals and you can't upgrade right now so
you have a 1080p television and this
works for you so but you want to partake
in your friend let's say your friends
online actually have 4k stuff and your
friends actually play these games with
their 4k television should you be
excluded from the group just because
financially you're not as flush in cash
as the next guy you you don't have the
ray-tracing in the 4k 60 but what you do
have is you have this blanket that keeps
you just as warm as the next guy and you
can partake and you can have fun with
the next guy isn't it about fun and
inclusion don't you want to be included
so wouldn't win a company tell someone
premium like you that's always say it's
not a role reversal because I'm still
buying an X I'm sure looking for a
television I'm still looking for these
things but at the same time I'm when I
turn on my xbox I don't want to leave
behind all the guys that can't do what
I'm doing
wouldn't win when I say hey you want to
play this for playing God fall and you
say damn it men I only have a four and I
say sucks for you step your game up how
did that make you feel was I really your
friend or was that some dude that was
just did because you was able to partake
in the same things that I was a male he
is a good super chair but we have a
bunch we got about yourself we still got
a code with the fire we had so much
misunderstanding about how game
development works especially from those
who have zero experience with
development
we got okay we have the $2 code with
facts not just graphics either then we
have gaming Forte with a 5 LS you can
chat if you want the best console
experience get the series exit you want
top-line performance that you control
bill to upgrade a PC choices yo and we
got a $5 super chef from pixel bit G at
some point soon bass Xbox one and s will
not be able to play new games natively
but they will be able to run X cloud
that's one way to handle the sunset
you've got a $25 super chair from
Optimus code I'm not saying no question
I'm only saying we can get one tired of
the showcase hardware at launch I mean
full potential
hey I in the works it looks like he's
saying that the work stuff beyond stuff
beyond just prettier great brass alright
alright got the one from oh I don't even
know what currency that is did not take
Vantage of the PS launch polish I don't
mean I know it's currency that's a good
question man and ultimately it proves
the point that there's a lot more to the
story than just the hardware it's
running on talent art direction is one
of the biggest ones obviously but any
resources man for the for the SDK and
all the software optimization is
difficut at the time yeah Rhys Rhys 100%
maxed out the base Xbox one just like
Forza 5 did this is what dan Greenwald
said he said that used 100% of it but
what happened was over time those dev
kits and the software got even better
ass and the indie band games always look
better that's why no matter what
hardware you're running on for the first
year or two games never fat end up
looking completely different than what
they did at the launch that are the end
of the previous ones and that's why they
always end up looking a lot better than
the next
I wonder fear or two the first year or
two that I like Moody's talking about
the last year or two
I like this next super chest name we got
a $2.00 super chap for one bad mother--
how many early Jan tech demos are you
and your top five nice let's deal with
some appointment cuz that is literally
what I said verbatim too and I we had
adequate going it was it was so bad like
the the phone and he thought he was
almost like I was talking to della
almost at the party I think we're not
gonna be leaving I'm like don't leave
what do you got we got so petty that he
went to a developer source that we both
know the developer Cordy read earlier is
basically saying the same thing that I
said that I said look things are a
little bit different now you could scale
things bah blah blah and at the end of
the day like you know there are things
that are scalable but you're really not
gonna be missing a whole lot either way
like these games are gonna look insane
and really that's ultimately what
matters man people are so focused on
things they don't even had their hands
on in terms of negative stuff when you
should really be appreciative of their
performance you really you're gonna get
yeah absolutely I don't give it to you
so I don't you chomping it to get you um
the only point I made like I said we
deal you know as far as the development
cycle and development kids in games
improving over the course of the
lifecycle of the console and in the
beginning like I said you know if you
look a lot of the beginning titles even
ones that were just solely made for said
console right and you compare it to
later in a song I'm talking about I
bring stuff back in the day king
remember like when 64 came out you saw
the early games and the remember we saw
like Donkey Kong Country for the first
time you were like how are they doing
this you know say as far as the SDK kids
it just dings over time and learning
techniques and being more official
getting more comfortable with the
hardware I think the vibe I'm getting is
dead
giving these guys that the past
generation that cushion to not cut them
off right for the first year or two once
year two or whatever it is that it
happens there's going to be a cut-off
there's going to be I think he actually
said holiday of twenty twenty-one days
worth
okay gasps are you ready guys my only
take on this is this this is the first
time that a company is being truly
transparent to your face right and when
Matt bootie Sydney's accent he was asked
a frank question he answers the question
this is the same Christian at all times
right you know so when you guys say oh
yeah you know I want to see something
that maximizes the power of my system
from the beginning you always see upward
taking resolution you always see an
upward take and graphical graphical
fidelity you always see that anyway
that's going to be evident okay what you
are trying to do is classism all right
and and you're being fooled by Sony
Talking Heads they have nothing to talk
about but a logo it had a new car on
stage so right now me in the bushes so
when they tell you well you know what
God for could only play on PlayStation
five and that's gonna show you the power
of our system you fell for the bait you
fell for the banana in the tailpipe you
said to yourself yeah man I want
something to show the power my system
they gonna be out here only whatever
stupid we can't be back a pet so so that
that's telling you their philosophy is
not inclusion is exclusion all right so
we know when a philosophy is all about
inclusion but you know madhubuti told
you we got you for two years and you're
gonna start seeing at the level of
difficulty change where we no longer can
you know drag these people along with us
but one share in the ecosystem all you
count along and everything is gonna go
forward so when you make the transition
over to the next system you're ready in
pocket these games
he said classism he said we talk about
gaming we ain't talking about the French
Revolution King you know we're really
learning from this we're learning why
these big companies stopped being
transparent with people in the first
place yes yes you know listen I told you
all before there's three people that I
watch for my news on gaming right and
I'm telling you these dudes just
cranking it out in this in this and not
in any particular order it's you know
dealer ran and Colt you know either way
flip flops and I was talking to COG last
week about it and I said you know they
put out the information and they have
these sources and stuff like that but
they they respect these sources to the
point where when he gets to okayed that
he shoots the video so you might have a
video in the morning but he got the OK
in the afternoon so he gonna shoot that
video at night because he's sitting on
stuff all right um if deal is not
ringing a bell talking about all hell is
breaking loose be careful mm-hmm stay
calm you know stay calm because he
actually knows more than he's saying
right now he's sitting right here
laughing to himself inside himself with
stuff that he knows already
no one forward now I'm not privy today
we'll get to that part later on in life
well then I could laugh to myself with
things but when I told your stuff with X
cloud and how Xbox was moving guys is
laughed at me when I told y'all before
with the always online remember y'all
was afraid to always online in the
digital oh my god the world is crashing
a party we do it you let me get sucker
saw baby baby be patient man so just
love listening to all the different
tapes but at the end of the day my
feeling is this um Microsoft's way of
their when you're when there's one way
of quantifying success right let's say
console sales whatever right right when
you're not winning in that regard what
do you do if you're smart you change the
conversation right Microsoft changed the
conversation right we started talking
about engagement whatever and then they
they shifted their entire focus to
creating
a fluid ecosystem with game paths and
that is what they care about right and
in order to continue to nurture that
ecosystem you have to make it consumer
friendly so that everyone feels that
they're always involved in whatever the
newest thing is in some way shape or
form even if they cannot purchase the
newest thing that is that's to me that
makes the most that's the most
forward-thinking way of thinking to
actually move the industry forward Sony
may very well continue to do they're you
know that the exclusives and the way
they've been doing it because that's
what's worked for them and that's fine
and I've talked about how if you don't
have the infrastructure in place to
actually follow suit with what Microsoft
is doing don't do it because it's not
your lane and you're gonna stumble if
it's not your lane right right um but to
be perfectly honest I think we have to
stop thinking about it in that way
because that it's it's one of those
prideful fanboys sort of chest-bumping
things to say oh my my system had has
these exclusives at the end of the day
though they said they've sold 106
million consoles okay how many of those
hundred and six million are hardcore
fanboys that care about that exclusive
stuff and how many of them are more
casual players that don't I'm glad you
brought that up because I was just gonna
say that yoga I saw the fraud or live in
effect a hundred and six million how
many times have you told that they were
one hundred and twenty six one hundred
and fifty million sold there was at
these really different numbers and then
you saw it in your face 106 I told you
the numbers never look right with these
dudes and every time we turn around the
numbers and stuff is being revealed by
these fraudulent doing 106 what happened
to that 126 and I 150 I just say I'm
just saying all the numbers look
speaking about numbers these what I'll
say before I go you people to like
numbers out there be ready to hear some
numbers you never heard before coming up
here soon
it might be at the end of this month so
hey just again just be prepared
y'all like numbers everybody saying Xbox
ain't doing goodness and that just be
sure to screencap some stuff regarding
certain things and I'm gonna leave you
guys that I mean last thing before I
move on on to the question people like
well angle by Series X to two years
today exclusive only series X title what
do you say to that song that's just
particularly saying these people are
frauding today was never go bad it's
like it's a fake argument to have like
then don't get it like play it on your
ass and be happy and just understand
what you're getting in relation to the X
and on PC accept that and understand it
and be good about it on again you're
creating a fake narrative that Microsoft
isn't engaging in anymore they were
engaging in that narrative I'd be like
oh yeah they're in trouble they're not
engaging they took the conversation
another way because the way the quantity
the way success was being quantified did
not benefit them 100% that is what
happened right the conversation that is
a smart thing to do that said I think
what they've done is 100% consumer
friendly where where the industry should
be going right and I think that's you
know and if Sony doesn't at least follow
suit I know Sony's gonna be very a
little bittle to in the water a little
bit and then you know little by little
sort of get-get in this flow make
perhaps I think if they do that it is
gonna be that way they're not gonna just
jump in a hundred percent headfirst um
but I think this is the way to go and at
the end of the day like I said it's a
dumb argument to have I honestly do any
shoutout to code right called 100% we
don't have the understanding about
development that you do from a technical
perspective
100% I think what little we do
understand in terms of like scalability
things like that I think your point is
100% valid but I think what I think the
business aspect of creating an ecosystem
that is friendly across multiple devices
matters more to them then whatever a
little bit of technical stuff they could
possibly get out of focusing on on the
top tier right so I think both points
are valid I just think for long-term
business and what they're trying to do
with their ecosystem I think this is the
way they're going to go I think this is
the way it makes sense to go across the
board in the industry goes final final
thoughts the whole thing yeah real talk
you should be anyone should be examining
do I need to buy an xbox Series exit
launch that's unnatural good mentality
to have when you're looking at new
gaming is this for me do I need it that
should be for everything doesn't matter
if it's a new system or not now if
you're coming up on that and you're
saying yourself you know what I don't
think I need the series X because
Microsoft's gonna take care of me and I
can save the bread a bit dude that's
great what do I care that you do or
don't buy a series X right no I don't I
want it for me I'm gonna get it for me I
don't care what you're playing Halo
infinite on you're playing it and I
having a good time in my ecosystem is
ripe and enjoying it having a good time
sweet it would be a death toll from
Microsoft who was out sold two to one as
much as I loved them they were out sold
two to one more or less in this
generation it'd be a death toll for them
to say you know what we're leaving all
those people that did invest with us
behind come on Ron don't bring with me
and King said it I've said it on my show
we've said it so many of us have said it
game pass is the platform now Xbox is
the brand the hardware gate is gone
get rid of it I don't care about it I
don't care fun let's have fun in games
Shawn thought it was cold two dollars to
purchase novice correct about changing
the conversation listen man
just what it is you know they they have
gone to the ecosystem that is what they
want the console sales where you play is
not of a concern to Microsoft I've said
this a million times
gizmo and whether they were forced in
that position or not it doesn't matter
now that's what it is right adapting I
appreciate that adapting because that
means I get more from our money
everybody
this was the would everybody wanted to
here we go speed through Canada we've is
for long this will be very quick I know
stitch is not gonna love these topics
this is for you be are you at us stitch
though yet though you're alerted a lot
of stuff going on the rumors have cooked
back up figure out what's going on so
I'm obviously we did hear that is a new
report I believe it's um
Taiwanese newspaper digi times man
expenses by the way to try to get
information for them you gotta get that
for somebody else but I thought I was
trying to be cute is they got get it
where you at with your premium news
services series eggs reportedly a BTS
which model is gonna be in the works you
know I'm saying and apparently it will
have 4k support bigger car and it's
supposed to be manufacturing sometimes
in first quarter of this year plan to
launch mid 2020 with an updated CPU and
magnesium alloy body some of the
prevalent theory is that uh [ __ ]
Nintendo is not gonna sit idly by while
the fight editors Xbox series X appears
five is out here that mid 2020s which
pro coming in hot
to combat so I gotta bring it to the
room let's start with Louis all let's
get some positivity
I don't I will believe it when I see it
Tendo has never been the type to
directly respond to anything right so
beat me thinking as I you know just
thinking is okay if you want to really
combat the ex or whatever you bring out
Zelda on improved Hardware so you don't
have you know you don't have the
Boogaloo that the 30 frames per second
you know you have you have a really
beautiful smooth Zelda experience and
that could combat you know it's the
launch of the other two consoles but
that's something that Nintendo doesn't
do they don't care but they're they're
totally in their own lane so I listen if
any of this is true 4k support bigger
cars ideas if all of this stuff I want
this I want this but I will believe it
when I see it when I see a direct this
says Nintendo switch pro and all that
stuff in it I'll pass out on the floor
right now it's cool we go what I want to
say this before as it goes what do you
think all right what do you want from a
series bro what do you boy
what would be the ideal thing for you
then you will be like you know what I'd
beid this from it improve CPU so we can
get them frame rates up yes in terms of
the screen absolutely you know at least
a 1080p IPS screen if you're talking
higher than that whatever Lucy hey if
it's premium like that I'll pay that
money but you know
dynamic 4k is dynamic so chaser those
are big numbers are thrown out there and
that would be unprecedented in a mobile
device unprecedented first times a
Nintendo is at the cutting edge of
technology when again took me a 4k
screen on a portable gaming system with
a fool CPU that thing would be a
fireball so I won it don't get me I want
it I just [ __ ] oh you're going to
have an ice box they had the opportunity
when they did the light and then they
are like you know what we're gonna give
you this incredibly cool looking device
for the light uh or you can't dock it
though you know the one thing the switch
is suppose real I've loved Nintendo they
do something special to get a magic
about him but man keep it up at the
times it's not one of them when switch
came out March 2017 that thing is
underpowered come here to all of them
still outsold it's still doing its thing
respect like what do I need I'll get
Brett the wild and 4k no think with like
garbage just garbage what do you want
more pixels on on your ad on this
Nintendo does not need a pro at this
point okay first of all would I buy yes
we don't need it just wait just wait you
know what they're gonna do to combat the
new systems breath well - that's right
really good
we're real if it were true it was to
have it what would you want from us
which bro none of the things that can be
truly offered without without that
anything I would want out of it is gonna
bump that price to skyrocketing how you
gonna keep the cooling how are you gonna
get those games truly at 4k you need
more assets and they knew everything I
would want is just gonna rock it into a
cost and category that I just don't it
would be a masterwork of design and
engineering but never before a seam in
the rough I was done I know what you I
know what you're pointing to King and
there's no discrete graphics card in
that just you know listen okay so
alright the elephant in the room is this
and this is why people are buck wild
bananas about this this I love when CES
comes through and then we got all this
wild speculation these dudes talk about
I got inside information and you know
what all this goofy stuff all right day
goofy reputable their careers correctly
predicted delight listen he's directly
predicted not no 4k alright he could
stop that right there he got a pump the
brick but this is Trudeau timeout they
probably could do 4k pitches
alright listen just because they say
they can do 4k on the box don't mean
it's really 4k we you can do 4k pictures
like you might get a screenshot that's
okay alright listen what happened on CES
if y'all was looking a Lea we're release
or showed a prototype of like a switch
looking handheld that was playing PC
games that were in a higher fidelity and
a higher framerate that's a switch right
yes so when I posted it I posted it in
the chat it's not something that we're
gonna talk about because it's not real
tech it's just something that they're
showing around and if it does come to
fruition
they have the basic backgrounds of the
bare bones of it to push it forward and
they're seen if there's enough interest
in something of this nature to go
forward with it now you have the switch
Pro I don't think and I think except it
is is definitely on to something with
this I don't think they need to because
with their software they have been
dominating the competition they have the
ones I've been dropping those Triple A
bangers just for the years right so when
when when Sony says did they drop in
triple-a mangas yeah but Nintendo has
been on your neck too you know and it's
bended they've been outpacing Microsoft
when it comes to that regard as well
sorry just so jus Luigi man should have
been adding just told you Pokemon
they're not telling you these in
hyperbole they're telling you this
because this is what the masses is
playing and in his reflecting in a sales
so and they're not telling you Hardware
numbers they're telling you sales
numbers and software so yeah no no no we
know what the hell they doing
listen places oh my I'm worried yeah
here's the thing let me get right into
it right let me get my for ordering all
the way live right I'm gonna turn this
on now for you know like on shout the
beat gave life sim finite I super chat
enjoy the show y'all brothers keep doing
your new PJ's like he always been in the
comment section with me that's my guy
listen I'm trying to keep this run going
but I can't front kick that series X
that PS 5 it got me shook but so whole
year away it's this is the year right so
here's the thing the reason why I'm
shook is that because let's be real as
much as y'all clown us on the widget
report and we do right guys every more
understood at the switch even has it
right make that it's scalable down and
you can be done stress which users can
actually experience even though it's
that the word fidelity we're gonna get
it there but at least they can
experience it
my point now is when you get the the
hell blade to in the you know the PS 5
okay I worried that they not gonna get
that third-party support that helped
them stay in the conversation by having
a Mortal Kombat 11 poor but how you're
not I'm saying like that can sustain
them they kept them in the mix but the
first party supporters exactly what did
it now okay now let's say the the
PlayStation 5 comes out and the X comes
out and they come out a week apart from
each other and in the middle of that
week or before their week breath or well
two comes out oh no doubt so do you
think that they need this shuttle shift
or sway in any matter right it'll keep
them afloat in the beginning but the
haymakers going so you okay so you want
to get the lesser titles on a lesser
system to what I'm gonna speak for
myself
yeah I know right I was I'm a sega kick
going through I grew up with Sega right
Nintendo I respected them but I was not
them dude right
I did buy every Nintendo system up until
about after the 64 GameCube I was like I
don't like the direction did not like
the Wii I felt it was war like a fad
you know I respected people who had it
will you you know how I feel about that
in the bushes which is for me portable
and the fact they had third-party
support and allow it mature titles these
are things I've been screaming at
Nintendo for the longest where's your
third cell party support where's your
mature titles we've know about your
first party y'all gonna do that so to me
yes their first party will keep them
afloat but for me when I have X cloud
right and I have all these things that
are looking vastly superior in this
ecosystem and then I turn them on and I
have but no stitches on the southern
side other 6660 mm for the one dollar
and 99 cents to perch at Cog but is it
worth having experience if it's bad
it's not about best my questions not
about bad experience it's about the fact
that it even exists I could continue
playing a game that I love on the go
that's all it is
I'm willing to sacrifice the the
fidelity
you don't say a little bit so that I
could just have it and continue my
expect that swai I love when there's
cross play or whatever like cross save
but trust what you know stuff it's an
extension that's how I look at it I
don't know if it comes up it's gonna
release with destiny to I would like the
power bomb of a pro so that more ports
can continue to come that's all I'm
saying
real quick shouts of beats games and
life $5.00 super chat and join the show
y'all brothers keep doing what y'all do
thank you sir to be honest with you like
they want to do a pro cool I doubt all
bye like they already did the Pokemon
like to me and I feel like the mass
majority people that buy switches they
bite for their first party exclusives
they don't buy you know it's cool that
the third party start there
my cousin you know he only plays stuff
on the switch he'd be playing overwatch
every night and I'm just like you got a
xbox like but he likes to switch he
plays everything on the switch so you
know it's cool that that's on there and
I'm sure that they really enjoy that
because it gives them the opportunity to
make money off that but for the majority
of the people you know my cousin bought
it for Super Smash Brothers he didn't
buy it for overwatch it was just
something that was there right is just
that um you know with the whole you know
if it is true you know I'm saying I
don't think it's at best it may be a 4k
upscale dock you know they're at best
you know my things can we have Bluetooth
please can we have Bluetooth no can we
have wireless I think what I just I just
bought I bought just bought like a $20
Bluetooth adapter works well but again
you had to buy an adapter
you know can we have like I think that's
the biggest thing that I okay can we get
a fully functional switch I mean listen
listen let's stop worrying about the
next switch let's fix this no no no they
don't do that don't do that for me the
best me doing something for me what
doing something for me is fixing what I
purchased already and I still got listen
I still have my original switch with the
little control of things that I can take
or I got a real switch one that I could
dock and play and move it
I got a switch what it really intended
to be I don't gotta stand still they
brought up a stupid standstill and they
lower the resolution and need lower
stuff now this is stop taking away from
me and give me back what I asked for you
have not brought them what was that
store the child I told you wasn't even
coming well I told you it wasn't coming
that y'all thought y'all was looking at
the Virtual Console I told you Nintendo
was gonna nickel-and-dime you see I pop
out your head and they did exactly what
I said I think y'all should start
calling Mina Nostradamus what was going
on young guys sat there you laughed at
me you're still waiting right now I
think you're just out next quick
yesterday I'm so sick and tired of this
switch yeah I don't even know how is
winning and they keep taking away stuff
real quick when if this is true I think
it comes out what are you gonna do with
your save states because you know they
don't wanna sleet Rance fur they don't
have a cloud oh you're right you got to
pay
but let's not act like clouds for every
game either
it's only true and if your money tends
to lapse that month type it in there
it's all gonna hunt hours and breath of
all day long but you know what Rio will
let you play there's not what to do his
Pokemon topic
yeah he got beat by Jessica you know one
doing two hours yeah we watch direct I
heard it's $30 over price we talked
about $30 each one about this director
yeah well I'll say is that I saw x-bar
expansion pass was trending and that can
only help me right let's get up out of
here man so do i LP pole with the booty
regarding the Xbox series X having new
exclusive games at launch do you agree
with the cross-gen strategy by Microsoft
to start a new generation the choices
are a oh hold on game a bunch wow wow
thank you brother $20 to watch a great
show thoroughly enjoy topics and panel I
am definitely looking forward to gaming
next generation hit the like and
subscribe but y'all my brother game on
your body
nobody forces so here's the choices are
a know Microsoft needs to showcase the
full power of series X and not be held
back by old hardware B yes series X
Games will still
the superior version cross-gen is a
smart move or see I don't care the power
of switch Pro exclusive negates anything
Series X will release it's ready to rock
the ILP when it goes up later this week
first of all I am Lord salute and shout
out to Lord it's separate ghost rocking
with our own embryos it's absolute
pleasure to have you in the room we can
define people find you and what do you
have going on sir gentlemen thank you so
much for having me and very sincerely I
appreciate any of you that are willing
to check out xep the Xbox expansion pass
on your podcast services means the
absolute world to have joined you today
and for anyone that does check it out
thank you so much you can find me on
Twitter at insipid ghost and I welcome
any and all conversations on the topic
of game
I appreciate you every keep me on track
GP drops every Monday every single
Monday at midnight in your podcast
service of choice everything from I
Heart Radio and Pandora all the way to
the heavy hitters of Spotify we are in
the fourteenth episode drops at midnight
tonight so I'm looking for shoes at
exclusive xep that's right that's right
and I had a few guests lined up for
later on in January they're gonna drop
some hardware knowledge not not next
hardware but maybe uh something to hook
you up with your headsets and the like
exciting I like to spotlight some stuff
so it's a salute to the ghost man the in
separate one not bland in my big dealer
gaming who pulled up absolutely
hilarious
RDX pockets one of the best xbox
podcasts go and bleed where'd it go out
addict Tuesday's that I forget eight I
think today but salute audio files in
the chat you already know what time it
is those are fellow friends of the
realms always pleasure to have him in
here Lord at extinct
on his square fighting off the evil
generation warriors yeah Lord at Excel
did yeah I was very proud of him you
know we fought he cut the phone off
allegedly on me later Bobby what do you
have uh sir
you can find me on Twitter Lord addict
IOP you could find me training in this
Pokemon Jam to come back at jazz with
twice the minutes yeah we're taking that
punch in the nose and just eating that
you gotta fight back like you did with
like you do first off you know we had a
log you didn't beat me
yes I did I beat you know it goes from
it goes from okay you did do better than
I thought you did but we won the two out
of way away
everyone was I was up to the third match
we can do it again but your first I want
to appreciate everyone can watch ok I
think I think there is like 234 40
people in the chat you know and all of
you guys are the reason we come here
every Sunday
except for King he comes here to talk he
comes here to make fun of people but you
know we all come here to give you guys a
good show you know I want to take our
guest he was a great guest and I don't
want to think solving because he's
playing control
today absolute pleasure boys sabe feisty
softer day the hallways levels Microsoft
killing it with the facts and the
knowledge waked at five people father
buddy I'm going awesome yeah first I'll
turn snippet goes for coming through
dealer coming through the doubt
knowledge and of course family to the
realm optimist cold definitely grout
with ringing it or shout out to him a
man you know you know me I'm about to
head out to work oh man do I need that
they need to update Wi-Fi again you you
know me that's the thing but you know me
I'm I wanna know you know I'm always
it's not the great but you know we do
what we can so you know catch me on our
Twitter loss of IOP mmm could be
examined on PSN xbox live shaming
business shaming switch as well if you
notice I had turned off the camera and I
went over there and I turn that light
let that green shine do you know what it
is whenever you feel like these are Sony
dudes is on your neck look to Green
Lantern the next kos will be up this
week I'm sorry this week this guy I have
under the weather
I'm trying to get the videos and stuff
together I have a backlog of statues I
actually have a couple of statutes
upstairs that I gotta bring downstairs
they got in I got a exclusive so next
week you can get two Kos going up next
week and with a quick one following next
week early in the week I have the custom
low key that I was telling you guys
about from Zion art that is impeccable
as 1/4 scale its
so big in paws I had to go buy a table
for it all right so you know I go to our
mic here I pick up the little $10 tables
so I got it you know get a little
separate table for it and it's it's it's
such a beautiful statue so I'm gonna do
an unboxing and on on okay I Wes I tell
you where to get your customs from I'm
not gonna be like certain other people
that hide it out and try to sell it to
you but a different price um but you can
find me at a King Day Lord no King David
OTW or Twitter yeah yeah and also combat
talk with the King on Lords of gaming
dotnet if you have not been the Lords of
gaming dinette please go to Lord
together down there and check out all a
wonderful content that we do have their
check out that e-string store so you can
get these beautiful shirts um I want to
give a shout out and I'm gonna give a
hand clap to the e3 2020 compound team
the rooms are full mm-hmm
so everybody we reached out to if you
didn't get in you didn't get booked the
rooms are full we have ten of the
industry's finest with us shout out to a
lot of them and we're gonna reveal those
people at a later date yeah but uh like
I told you before we will be in
Hollywood we are in Hollywood all right
I told you before we the move is one
unit we love movies more than we got any
moves how it coming it's it's it's gonna
be a movie um also I'm gonna say shout
out to separate ghosts I met a separate
goals at fan fest and this is why I like
fan fest this why like Microsoft this
this is this is why he's he's a direct
reason why Menem was playing for a lot
of you freud's out there they're like to
hate on Battletoads he and I was playing
Battletoads right and he can tell you
from
an experience from touching the game the
game is way better than you guys will
ever believe and know until you actually
get it in your hands and one of the main
components to that game is the audio but
when I was talking to him I hand him my
business card not knowing that it will
lead to exists
beautiful day of stayed with me and this
is the camaraderie and the friendships
that you build facts over getting off
your butt and going to your shows if you
are a fan and you represent this culture
you owe it to yourself to get up get out
and start participating Gaming is not
just any on your couch get up get out
meet and you see what happens yeah so I
remember the day very very vividly I
remember everything about it and I say
it was a great day because I felt the
energy that day and the energy has
brought us back to here so thank you and
separate girls for coming through and
I'm so happy that a friendship was made
so far away
CACO said you owned your own outcast he
said get up get out everybody I know we
went long but we had to get these topics
in it was fantastic
again saluted his ghost he's killing it
man will do more with him also the
future and then again still to the chest
with the Lords of gaming dotnet man this
is our moment I want to give it to you
guys you guys have been killing it and
we got more things to show everybody
please enjoy your Sunday thanks for
rocking us what a chat was fantastic
that's all I got man playoffs is
continuing let's go everybody enjoy your
day Sunday let's go Raven